the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
welcome back to day three of the St
Louis super Swiss I'm feeding Master
Doug Eckert and I'm almost Grandmaster
stop being a pleasure and we're very
excited to be back with commentary for
round five
so first we're going to look at the
results from round four from last night
on board one we had fide Corrales losing
to Grand Master Nicholas theodoru for
two we got a draw between elshon and
elianiznyk board three Lazaro bruzon
beat International Master duden we had a
win by Casita Perez on board four
against Aaron burbinski a draw on board
five between harshit and a Cobian and a
win for Christopher you on board six
against Irene sukhandar a draw by Brian
Escalante against Brandon Jacobson and a
win on board seven against Alice Lee a
win by Darius making a comeback after
that very instructive game that he lost
yesterday Dennis boros won a nice game
and Costa kovitzki also was a winner
last night so a lot of Fighting Chess
last night and
uh last
boards Josiah stairman won against Caleb
Denby Evan Park Drew against Gabriela
antova Talia Cervantes came back with a
win against Alex Marlin
um David zurbinski won against Ralph tan
Eugenia yanai Drew against Alex Zhang
and Lyndon Lee won his game against
Julian perlacon there were a couple of
buys as well some requested some were
given because it's a odd number of
players
let's get into the tournament format
so the tournament format is a nine round
Swiss the time control is game in 90
minutes with a 30 second increment for
move one there's no secondary time
control in this tournament and that
makes the games much more interesting I
think
going forward let's review the schedule
of this Swiss super Swiss tournament so
the rounds typically take place for at
11 A.M in the morning and then there's a
second round at 5 p.m
um we start we already went through
games one through four right now we are
March 14th with game five and uh
tomorrow we will be doing commentary for
Rounds seven and then the last day on
March 16th it will be the final round at
11 A.M central time so
um just uh we are passing the halfway of
the tournament today with round five
we are not doing commentary for the
afternoon rounds however the games are
still broadcasted on leeches so you're
welcome to to stay
on track with that and of course feel
free to tweet at San Luis chess club or
use the hashtags STL super Swiss you can
also follow the results and information
about the tournament on us chess
champs.com and
of course follow us live on both
sandwiches clubs YouTube and tweet pages
of course we're going to be very excited
to interact with the chat so we are
we're happy you're here with us
hopefully you'll stay here for uh the
rest of the day and the next two days as
well all right let's go on and check out
the pairings for today's round five
so on board one we've got Nicholas
theodoro who is the clear leader of the
tournament against Casada Perez and
board two we have mikhailan antipov who
took two half Point buys yesterday and
is back in Action today playing
Christopher you and Darius schwerz
against
um and again I can't remember
I hope that's correct it doesn't roll
off my tongue very well so and we have
two former Webster teammates playing
each other in ilionizedek and Fidel
Corrales and St Louis favorite Vara
Cobian is playing another St Louis base
Grand Master Dennis boros very
interesting pairing there with a very
positional player against a very uh
attacking-minded player and Brandon
Jacobson against Josiah Stearman and
Brian Escalante against elshon Costa
kubwitzky who's also a favorite here on
the website against harshit Raja and
vasif who took some buys yesterday is
back in action against Aaron Jacobson
Aram pacobian is playing Evan Park and
so some very interesting pairings and we
also have you know local chest Talent
Talia Cervantes back on the boards that
we'll be watching today
and there's a second page for the final
pairings for we have a lot of players in
this tournament so you guys can see
Aaron Granby grabinski playing against
David zurbinsky Alice Lee is playing
another female women's International
Master
Sila chaglar Gabriela antova against
National Master Linden Lee
Caleb Demby who
has had maybe a tough tournament but
he's facing the woman's Grandmaster
marianovich Maria malishka against
Eugenia naid Ralph tan against Nicolas
ladan and then we have a few buys some
one full point buy to Alex Young due to
the odd number of players and then we
have three requested Half Point buys but
I think that's enough with our preview
of what is going on and keeping you
updated with the tournament I think it's
time for us to get into the games
especially with board one
um Nicolas theodoro has had a brilliant
game yesterday against Darius feards we
have seen it live we were I I was
particularly impressed with that game it
gave me
um Casablanca tray ball Vibes the way he
was able to win that game and he's
keeping the lead with three and a half
out of four he's facing
so let's uh let's get into this game
so they went home for a Sicilian
E6
C3 all right the alapin
and oftentimes this can transpose into a
French
do you are you playing this uh yourself
as a correspondence player I have not
played this recently I have played D5 as
black in this position before and
normally on the capture here I would
take back the queen queen which is not
what happened in this game I think this
is kind of a main line and white usually
goes D4 and there are various variations
where this queen gets retweeted somehow
to D6 or D7 eventually ends up there the
bishop goes to D6 and they're really
long theoretical lines I think here I
used to play this with black myself
whether I was starting off as a French
or a sicilian and yeah those but it
seems that black decided to go for a
more
um quiet possibly it's quiet and and I
think when you mention a French it's
similar to the tarash you know variation
of French with 3 Knight D2 for white
these types of positions I I'm not a big
fan of playing the isolated Queen Pawn a
Tempo down with black so that's why I've
never played the E takes D5 variation
and now you can take with the queen and
then there's sometimes this line where
you actually get to take the pawn and
then white will regain it I don't know
if there's Bishops C4 first but I was
referring to the lines because I could
play e takes D5 here okay is very the
the positions are similar to this
position right that they're getting into
in the game the only thing is in that in
this position we have the bishop that's
blocked which could be an issue
um and the other one we have the pawn in
C3 which stops the knight from going to
C3 pretty much every single opening is
gonna have its pluses and minuses you
just need to to figure out what you're
more confident or yeah confident to play
um when when you have to play over the
board and sometimes you play against the
opponents at this level
um at their level I think a lot of these
players spend a lot of time preparing
and it goes on psychology as well yes
for a lot of the people watching us
maybe that's not something that they do
yet but if you are considering to become
a stronger player you definitely need to
take that into account and sometimes
having a coach to guide you on how to do
those things might be important I I do
some opening preparation for some of the
players and certainly we're looking at
the games of the other players and
positions that they feel comfortable
playing and not feeling comfortable
playing and it's a matter of you know
going to your player's strengths versus
that other players perceive weaknesses
yes yes and yes I I'm just saying the
position that black chose to play here
is not one that I particularly like the
structure to play as black
I've played these positions with black
and sometimes I actually consider to go
C4 although not a move that is typically
recommended because you usually want to
have the pressure in the center
this move oftentimes allows B3 to break
through this chain very fast but
as a kid I noticed this move worked
quite well for me as an adult I don't
know if it will work as great there's
usually a capture and then eventually
white is going to have potentially
something that we've discussed in
another game yesterday with the hanging
pawns when you get to play C4 and and
and that would happen it's a little bit
different here than that game but yeah
I've played this position before
actually as white and strategically this
is a complicated position to play
because when you do play C4 you've
created you know a hole on B4 so the
white pawns can be a strength or a
weakness it's not a very easy pawn
structure to play for either side here I
I totally agree but it looks like
quesada decided to go for Knight to C6
instead and Bishop B5 very natural and
you have to be careful sometimes with
black on how you're going to deal with
the opening of the file you need to make
sure
I think I fell for something like this
one time I wish I remembered exactly the
move order but if you're not careful to
develop your 1987 and by mistake you
choose to put it in F6 there are some
ideas with with this check here and if
you go for example Bishop E6 now there
will be some Knight g5s potentially at
some point and and the pawn structure is
going to be destroyed so you have to be
a little bit cautious with black
but I think uh it's yeah it's not it's
not that difficult to to play and with
the 1987 it doesn't protect H7 but it
will have ideas to come to G6 which will
lock this diagonal
um against potential attacks and um
and the Knights are protecting each
other so yeah I think it's kind of funny
here because when we go through the next
couple moves here I believe that this
has transposed directly into those three
Knight D2 lines that we were talking
about in our friends here this is
precisely the position you get with 3
Knight D2 and he takes D5 now of course
the Knight didn't go to D2 till move
nine and it goes there and move three in
the French yes but this is a
transposition that's right that is right
so
um okay so this is Theory I think still
this is uh this is definitely still
Theory and we're waiting on moves by
their Doro once again we want to say hi
to people who are watching us from both
YouTube and twitch thanks for being here
everyone
um there was a question
someone was asking about the Jacobson's
German game yes it does appear that game
was from yesterday and for some reason
it shows up as board six we are working
on having that fixed so
um hopefully that's going to happen soon
otherwise we'll have one game less to
look at today so there's a question here
does the commentary team prefer to play
with the hanging pawns or against them
uh I think it depends on how the other
pieces are placed and if you actually
get to attack them or not I had a game
recently where I actually had to play
against the hanging Pawns
and it was
um I was having a much better position
and then I messed it up so I think it's
difficult to play with or without them
that's the kind of Pawn structure you
definitely want to spend a lot of time
analyzing and understanding same as the
isolated Pawn because you have attacking
ideas but you also have to know some
defensive mechanisms and going towards
the type of position that will benefit
you so
um
I think it depends on how I feel each
day you know and I would say that since
with computers all positions are really
equal there's zero zero zero learning
how to play those positions from both
sides will give you a position that you
can play for all three results and again
I I feel probably more comfortable
playing against them because there's all
these little tactical tricks you can try
against them to try and
um you know take advantage of them and
someone mentioned that they now remember
me from uh Ben Feingold video and I I
played this very nice game against Ben
at the senior Championship a year and a
half ago and he had the hanging Pawn
structure in a a Czech benoni against me
where his pawns are on E5 and F5 and
even though my king was on the king side
I played G4 to undermine the pawns and
and then when he actually he took the
pawn on G4 and I had a Pawn on H3 and I
just pushed asked it with H4 and it had
the effect of closing all of the files
that black thought that he was going to
attack my king with and at the same time
it kept all of Ben's pieces out and it
was it was kind of a funny position
because I was a pawn down after I did it
and I I knew my position was a little
bit better and when I looked at it with
a computer after the game I was actually
already plus nine in the position even
though as a pawn down which was a crazy
evaluation yeah I ended up winning
because that Ben and the video that
Patrick is referring to here in the chat
is actually quite funny because Ben has
beaten me many games over the years and
we had kind of a funny chat afterwards
that you know after all the games of
this important game to bet I was
actually very fortunate to win against
them and he took the defeat very
graciously and I'm a good friend of his
but nice but but these types of
positions are fascinating to play and
I've I've lost some horrifically bad
games on both sides of them and I've won
some nice games as well
now that you mentioned that I do
remember that I had another game that
was very tough actually in U.S
championship against anything and she
had the hanging pawns and I thought I
had an easy way to attack them and I
completely missed an opportunity to that
she could
um just simply get to attack my king and
it was very unpleasant I ended up losing
a piece that game was um
yeah not one of my favorites for sure
but um that's what I was saying because
sometimes you know when you have the
hanging pawns you have a little bit more
space so it depends how they are placed
and how you get to attack them to to
Really weaken them if you get the chance
sometimes you attack them and you're not
careful and actually for them to push
forward it's actually helping the site
that has them but one thing I've learned
if you're playing against the hanging
pawns you want to be very careful let's
say if you're white and black has hangy
pawns on C5 and D5 you want to be very
very careful about trading either of
your Bishops off because those hanging
pawns when they they move forward so for
example if white trades this white
squared Bishop off and I I made this
mistake in a game for one of Black's
Knights all of a sudden that Bishop on
B7 is unopposed and you can very quickly
find yourself checkmated in those
positions so that's something that you
have to be careful but we should go to
to look at some other games here yes as
we're waiting for more moves on this
game this is definitely going to be one
of the games that we are keeping our
eyes on but as we're not receiving more
moves let's go to board two Michael
antipo who came after two buys yesterday
I believe he had two guys right yes yeah
he did and now uh Christopher you is on
board too against him and seems like if
the times are right seems like
Christopher is still in his preparation
let's see how this game
got into that position okay so B3
B3 some kind of close French or Sicilian
I don't know how I'd call this because
the pawn structure
is French bone structure yet it started
as a Sicilian
okay so we have a similar in a way Pawn
structure as in the previous game
however white didn't play D4
and it's not planning to do you think
white is going to consider long Castle
yeah I think so and it's shocking that
Christopher's still in preparation here
because this is not exactly a Mainline
opening and he's playing very quickly
and and black is allowing the exact
thing that you suggested could happen
here at Knight to G5 and fracturing the
bond structure yeah I'm a little bit
surprised about this last move of uh of
Christopher in Knight E7
um but again he played it almost
instantly it's just because of the
bishop being in B2 compared to the other
game where there's a pony C3 it's going
to be difficult for black to develop and
you don't want to push this too soon as
far as I know because then you're giving
up some squares you're also opening up
this diagonal unless you think it could
work here
but then night night uh night there's
probably not an option
yeah there's a comment that anthropov
wants to win yet I mean these are very
interesting openings you know while
they're offbeat I mean there's a lot of
pressure blacks under here in terms of
getting their pieces properly you know
placed because with the bishop on B2 as
Sabine pointed out that the black Bishop
on f8 is very hard to develop playing D4
concedes you know some holes on the
light squares that you don't really want
to concede early so getting the pieces
on the proper squares for black is not
that easy of a task and the fact that
Christopher is playing these moves
instantly is suggesting that he's looked
at this and and knows where he wants to
put his pieces in wine
I wonder if H6 would be an option here
for for black after D3 if we could play
H6 or maybe Christopher thinks that's a
waste of time
um if he doesn't
possibly care about the the losing of
his Livescore Bishop in ig5
because right
um
if we play H6 it could be an Awakening
move but in the same time we're not
allowing this
um and the question is where do we take
this Knight out I would
wait is this an option
I'm seeing a lot of things I'm this is
not something I'm the most familiar with
um you still have the issue of how do
you ever get the bishop f8 into play
yeah I was thinking with Knight F6
however obviously I need to do something
about the pain right now so
um maybe Queen D7
and then
um I would just go Knight F6 and then
yeah I'm wondering if I'm happy to give
us some crazy move like you know Knight
to H4 here with the idea of playing
Knight to G6 on the next move that's
funny I mean I and I have no idea it's a
stupid looking move but it's might work
uh you know I also have a very crazy
idea and that's right and you might have
to do that but I might have to yeah I
don't I don't know how good it is but
because I'm multiple weak right but I
might be happy here swapping on E6 and
um swapping everything ah wait I think
I'm losing something right here and then
taking your Pawn on G7 you don't take it
no I don't quite but it Rooks on H7 yeah
I don't think you moved the Knight yet
you can stabilize the night like that
for a little bit longer
but I will have ideas midnight here and
you don't have sufficient time to bring
another one
to defend this could be
um yeah Black's caught up in development
here so Black's probably fine I I would
think
I don't know if loncastle is something
we really really want to
do
yeah I mean someone is suggesting in the
chat here that Christopher's setup looks
difficult to play from the black side
and I I you know when you talk about the
setup here
you know he played a normal looking move
D5 on move four against this and then
play was somewhat forced after he
decided not to play Queen takes D5
to to get to this type of position and
you're absolutely correct it's it's very
difficult to figure out where to place
the uh the black pieces well he could
have captured with the queen in this
position and I think then he wouldn't
have struggled as much with the
development in my opinion I could be
wrong because you don't have the checks
obviously the king is protected and this
move can be helpful to the push of B5
Bishop B7 and proceed with the
development
um uh right but you still have the issue
of okay if you play Knight F6 maybe you
want white doubles the pawns at some
point I don't know okay but if like you
have to make a move here to Knight C3 I
was thinking is natural to play but
obviously if you do that then you won't
have Bishop takes maybe you can go
Bishop B2 or Bishop C4 and if you don't
want to let me play B5 if you have that
move of course as well but I think this
kind of position is a little bit easier
for for black to
um to arrange the pieces okay if I don't
get B5 and I can play Just B6 the bishop
definitely goes in B7 and I really think
this is not a bad this is not a bad kind
of setup for Black I could be wrong yeah
I've played it and I was comfortable but
you know you shouldn't you shouldn't
just play something because someone
tells you they are comfortable of course
you should spend some time understanding
the position yourself
but but he played quickly so yeah he
played quite far so I have the feeling
he's probably familiar with this
position
um even this move Bishop E6 which
clearly will allow at some point some
Knight G5 not right now obviously but
um
so it's it's kind of it's kind of
interesting that
um but what to do could he have played
no he couldn't have
yeah H6 is the only thing I can think of
but
um it could be another waste of time
this move the way that white chose their
setup and this is nice about openings
that don't have 10 000 moves of theory
and the exaggerated with 10 000 moves
but there are a lot of openings that
have very long lines of theory that you
have to memorize sometimes they'll move
30 40.
so when you are playing things like this
it is very important how you set up your
pieces at first because that just guys
the game towards something and if one
move is just out of out of place then uh
uh you might need a lot of other moves
to fix that you know wrongly placed
piece and really in a position like this
I think if black makes an air that you
may not be able to fix it because black
might very well be fine here but I think
you know playing very precisely is
important I think an air by black in
this position is Strategic Air of
putting a minor piece on the wrong
Square could be a losing air very early
in the game I agree I agree although it
seems that white is has played without
much ambition you don't know when
something can it just show up out of
nowhere and looks like finally we we got
a couple more moves in this position if
the time is right and tip of thought for
30 minutes
and he went for 92 in the end
I don't have control over the time I
let's hope it's correct but that is
crazy to spend that much time he
probably was thinking about Knight G5
and he probably found something that he
was unhappy with and then he was like
you know what I'm just gonna go for
something natural but 30 minutes is
quite a lot of time to spend when you
only have an hour 30 for the entire game
it absolutely is I I mean I play a lot
of these time control tournaments and I
am Norm tournaments and really in this
time control you have time to think
maybe three times for about 10 or 15
minutes a move and then if you're
spending on normal one or two minutes on
your other moves by the time you get to
move 35 or 40 you're on the increment so
if you invest 30 minutes on move nine
you've really limited yourself to maybe
one more thing the rest of the game
that's true that is true
but but let's see because
um because okay Knight G5 wasn't played
but maybe white was just developing
another piece to be one move away from
castling I think it was right here in
San Luis in one of the sinful cups where
um when they had the or maybe it was
uh Sanders rapid and Blitz
where
Magnus went to the this booth that they
had the confessional booth and he said
he was these games like you know if
you're one move away from castling you
are totally fine you don't need to worry
if you're two moves away from castling
it could go either way
and if your three moves away from
castling in an opening or in some
position after the opening is over then
you know that's bad there should be a
video somewhere
of that clip I always share that with
with my students just to remind them
that it's very important to Castle so
he's getting ready to Castle just in
case you know
um
and
um and now he waited to see how
Christopher was planning on developing
his bishop and it seems that he went for
Knight F5 I was thinking more like maybe
96 but he went from Knight to five oh
it's nice that we got on the screen the
standings as well with the pairings and
you guys can see how each players have
played it's right
under our names which is nice to see I
had not realized I was there I think
they the our team has just put it so
thanks for that
um so Knight F5 and now Bishop to H3 and
um what is going on now Christopher
started thinking now
we want to take the Knight
you cannot just develop that Bishop
what's going to be Black's continuation
because you cannot just move the Knight
you're losing E6
and I think the critical question is is
can black Play Bishop E7 or not
um you know we're saying you can Lop off
the Knight and take the pawn you've
given up your Bishop pair and
can we be this aggressive or no oh sorry
yeah so yeah it doesn't look like you
can play this looks wrong because you're
on down
maybe he can yeah I can't imagine black
has enough compensation here
so you can now play Bishop B7
so how are you in Queen E7
I know it looks very ugly but
your own move away from Castleton
you know Magnus Carlson gotta
well
yeah
um
and again Christopher has been playing
very very quickly here so again it's
hard to believe that he doesn't know
what he's doing but again black might be
fine here but it looks a little awkward
it does look kind of awkward the Knight
of five might have been played a little
bit too fast
but what else
also
this is a really sneaky kind of move you
know you're just prophylaxi a little bit
let's see where you go next maybe
Christopher could have played Queen D7
first
um with
that way he's not pinned so obviously
Bishop H3 is not an option so he's
giving white one more chance to
potentially Castle or do something
this bishop is a very bothering
very much bothering me I think I had to
play once against someone who played
this and I think I ended up just
castling long and putting the 19 F6 to
avoid these kind of situations
yeah so It's Tricky so but it's an
interesting game we should move on to
some other games here and we'll see how
that game develops
question before we go someone was asking
if we can explain the numbers next to
the oh so those are the players that
ended up playing against
um so
um the the numbers you see on the screen
are so like in round one uh
um Theodore won against uh number 28.
that's that's what it shows so number 28
in the standings so that's how you would
see that's how that's standing that
that's what it means
um you guys don't have a view of the
entire uh standing I don't know if
there's a command for that
um for you guys to to check the results
but
um
yeah but that's what those numbers mean
yeah so so apparently there is a
Leaderboard on lead chest that you can
link to and for example if you look at
Nicholas theodoro has a w against seven
so he beat Fidelis Fidel Corrales who's
right now number seven on the
leaderboard so that's the way
um that would work yeah that's that's
how those things are made that's what
yeah
just in case all right so
um
someone is also saying that they believe
Queen E7 is the only logical move I
don't see another kind of move in this
position either so
um I think that's
I mean another illogical move is King
here but I'm pretty sure you do not want
to make that move so yeah it's a little
bit early to make that desperation King
to D7
I I did have a game a couple of years
ago where I was on the black side of a
king's Gambit and I messed up the
opening and about moved 10 my only move
was King to D7 to charge my king over to
the queen side and I I survived but I
was very very lucky it's always scary
when you have to make make those kind of
moves for sure
um okay so we'll we'll return to this
game let's move over you are saying to
go to board three yeah let's look at
board three okay
so Darius had a tough loss yesterday
against the adoro and he's back
um today playing the white pieces
against Balaji dagupati so lots of
Sicilians today
line 97
okay
everything everything looks good so far
quite Theory even I know it which is
surprising because I don't play E4
very much
okay
Bishop V7 okay so uh I think they're
probably out of theory
um actually I don't know if D if E5 is
is a move for white to play this soon as
far as I remember for white
um when you go E5 you usually want to
get this D4 move in and there's usually
a pawn in D3 but okay because of the
move order that wasn't necessary
but I guess white has to make a decision
at this point are they going to capture
in D5 or go E5 they can't or D3 so those
are the three options so
um Dodgers decided to go for E5
um in this position it's
quite interesting and then black is
stopping him from getting D4 because if
white would get D4 in this position I
think
um
they they just have a great French
Pawn structure position so
um so he went for D5 right so for
example if this
you have Placer Bishop in B7 you don't
even have ideas with queen B6 to put
pressure on D4 anymore you will need a
few more moves you already developed the
Knight here so you need to make sure
this is an option and you're not gonna
be maybe it won't be chased away because
you have Knight H4
so that will be a good
potential idea for black
but ideas with F6 are not possible
anymore I think it's slightly it's
slightly more uncomfortable compared to
a French
so that's why he ended up Balaji most
likely played D4 because of that and now
he's trying to get that square for his
Knight
Darius does not commit to capturing he
plays D3 so he's keeping this option
opened to play C4 so you know white
doesn't get that square but of course he
does get so black doesn't get the square
D5 but he does get Bishop B7
and um
how to proceed here with white
Black's certainly going to place the
Knight here I believe followed by Bishop
E7
will we block
not yet maybe wait a couple more moves
with Knight to D2
bring the Knight towards
towards D6
Bishop F4 is another option for white in
this position yeah it's an interesting
position I think you know it's
more clear where black should put his
pieces but you know white has more space
and
you know it's double-edged I mean it
wouldn't Shock Me and the computer says
White's a little bit better here but
it's double-edged and it's a good
fighting position
I I agree it's we'll have to wait and
see how how he chooses to place his
pieces oftentimes white gets these types
of positions with the pawn in F4 and
those kind of situations there's an
issue with the E3 Square for white but
here those are not some issues but
usually when you end up pushing a pawn
forward and blocking them you tend to
want to play on that side of the board
and here
um
white will have to figure out how to get
this F4 in where he will move the Knight
will he just follow the typical kind of
ideas with H3 and hh2 and then start the
pawn Marge bring this other Knight like
I said
or is he trying to focus on the D4 upon
which you know when you push pawns
forward like this
without them being protected very much
there's often the opportunity to attack
them but I believe with white ever
chooses to take here black will not want
to capture back with the pawn so they
will always try to make sure they get a
piece if possible unless I'm mistaken
but I would prefer to have a piece and
um
not weaken my pawns what do you think
yeah I agree with that and you know in
these types of positions I I think white
wants to keep the pawn tension as long
as he can to put some pressure on black
to not be able to just develop his
pieces on the ideal Square
but I I can't say that I've spent a lot
of time looking at these particular
types of positions in my chest life I
haven't played it that often yeah I
haven't I have played some with black
but typically
I would have my knight developed in F6
so when this movie 5 was played in some
kind of French close French Pawn
structure this Knight would typically go
back to D7 or sometimes you would go 98
Knight C7 to later you know support some
kind of pushes and then getting the
Knight into play so when I played with
the 1987 I would typically have my
Bishop out and I would play F6 so that I
wouldn't allow these these kind of
pushes so there's always something that
you have and it's always nice to compare
the different positions so that you know
in the future what you want to do
to get especially if it's a
non-theoretical position we'll be back
with this game and um
quite a few moves here The Clash of two
favorites here in San Luis Where Have
You Been against Danish Borge both of
them have have been working
um
with the club on various videos on
YouTube so if you haven't done so yet
you can always check out sandwiches
clubs YouTube channel for other things
not just us being live uh also if you're
watching us on
twitch you can check out some of the
YouTubes too if you want
um okay so they played a qgd when it's
Gambit declined Bishop G5 this time and
yesterday
um
there was that game with the bishoping
B4 that VAR had well I think it was the
day before actually first first round
game VAR played against Nicholas London
and there was that idea that was played
against him and he seemed pretty
prepared he went over it he was very
kind to go over it yes and let us know
about his thoughts
so now Bishop G5
and uh this this game reminds me very
much of of the game that I mentioned one
time that I was inspired by Sam
it's actually it was really like this I
think yeah well this is an interesting
line because a Vladimir kramnik started
playing this system with Knight bd7 and
then an early C5 for black so this is
was popularized by kramnik maybe 10
years ago
and it's pretty solid for black I was
checking to see if my game is in the
database I was going to do that but um
no it's not it's not here
um this was my game against anything
this is the game I was talking about
um however I think she at some point
took she somehow took in D4 first uh how
that could have happened
I do not remember but this definitely
happened I took and then
um
I think maybe this no because she had
taken how could she have taken here
because um so what happened basically I
ended up everyone kind of you know plays
Bishop E2 here and then you know if you
take you take back with the Knight and
you have this quite balanced position
and you know everyone is expecting white
with Castle short and if you get you get
a very tiny plus possibly because this
bishop is not developed yet and is gonna
need a few moves but other than that
that's it it's very minimal advantage
and in this kind of situation Sabina
decided to be very aggressive and she
went for a long Castle don't make that
mistake
but I was like oh there's H6 I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna go G4 H for G5 and in
the end that game turned to be good but
I really would never recommend anyone to
Castle in this kind of position because
although it seems that black is not
ready to attack white skin there are
very easy ways to get a rook on the file
and because you don't have time to
you're already the file is already open
so you don't have time to just march to
A1 and just say oh that's fine because
as soon as the rule goes through C8 nine
comes here and then black can just mess
up your Pawn structure and then it's
gonna be bad you might not lose getting
checkmated but you will but you could
you could you could so don't don't do
that um this reminds me of that game
very well but VAR of course did not go
for the long Castle he went for the
short castle and
um
this is this is the current position
that we're having both of the players
have spent quite a bit of time
and the question is
can we try to find some ideas for why to
play for a win
I think this is the type of position
Farr is very comfortable in he's going
to put his effort on D1 as a rook on
probably C1 to hit the open files and
you know black has to solve the problem
of the bishop on C8 and if black can
solve the problem of the bishop on C8
he's probably equal and if not White's
going to have some type of small plus
and VAR really likes grinding small plus
positions that's his style and and you
know like I said earlier Dennis is an
attacking player so when Sabina was
mentioning you sometimes play on the
psychology of players I think this is a
good example of you know VAR has a quiet
position and he's perfectly happy in and
Dennis is playing a position that he
might be less happy playing because of
this style that's correct yeah I
remember how that my game I I went to
the psychology as well because my my
opponents at the time needed a draw to
become Champion so I mm-hmm
so yeah so sometimes when you're being
attacked you get uncomfortable no matter
who you are I think you still get a
little bit uncomfortable
and yeah I suggest to go back just uh or
should we keep going forward with a few
more of the games yeah why don't we look
at some more games here and why don't we
go to niznik and Fidel I always keep
that yeah
oh okay this is my kind of position and
it was kind of interesting as a side
note yesterday Fidel in round three won
this beautiful game where we thought a
ROM had this very deep preparation in um
the the nimso Indian where Fidel played
F3 on move four and then in the I I had
shown everybody this crazy line was C5
and B5 and which was way far away from
what happened in the game and then it
turned out Fidel hit white in round four
last night and he played an F3 nimso
again and the person played the line I
showed C5 and B5 against Fidel and
actually beat Fidel in 24 moves on the
black side of that which I I thought was
somewhat humorous I'm sure Fidel who's
also a good friend of mine didn't find
that very humorous and he doesn't know
the comment that I made but
so now he's playing now he's playing the
king is Indian
um but it's going to be a tough it's
going to be a tough match between these
two I think they were former teammates
right they're former teammates they know
each other very well so so G3 and G3
King is Indian okay oh no transposing to
some something that I like to call the
schlechter
um I don't know if that's the name
that's how I call it
uh what would you call this well I mean
I think the schlechter proper is when
white plays E3 so this is a a grunfeld
it's really transposed into two three
and you know this is a position again
that got popularized in the karpov
Kasparov matches where karpov was on the
white side of these positions and
this is one of the main reasons why G3
isn't that popular against the king's
Indian along with potentially
transposing into nimso as White's been
beating his head against this position
for 30 years without making a dent
it is kind of tough when
when suddenly You Know You're Expecting
someone to play D6
owned and it's not like you can stop
this D5 because depending on the kind of
move over order that you play if C6 like
it's not like you can just go D5 I mean
you could but I think that pawn is going
to be potentially lost
Maybe not immediately but
because
is this yeah is this lost is it lost I
think it is right can you do that oh wow
yeah right because this is this is a
very typical trap you don't want to fall
for bam
I had some students who fell for this
for for black for black but yeah you
think oh I got I got a piece thank you
very much no you don't you don't get the
piece and uh and suddenly You're Gonna
Lose the queen so
um is this Pawn I think this Pawn is
lost so people don't play D5 I'm sure if
this was a move they would have played
it long time ago
but but yes when you push pawns forward
too much and you don't have uh the right
kind of artillery to defend those pawns
that's going to be an issue so
um anyways
moving on Knight C3 and oopsie I went
directly to the final position which you
guys had seen already
Okay so
Queen B3 was played by Ilia just trying
to to keep on the pressure he doesn't
want to take here too soon because that
allows Pawn takes and then black has a
you know symmetrical Bond structure he
gets to develop the 1966 where it's
comfortable I think there's some line
with 95 that's yeah this is the main
line yeah but I mean again it's been
analyzed to Quality so it's just beating
your head against the wall
so he tries to put some pressure and by
having the queen in B3 and the pressure
here you are also putting pressure in B7
not letting black black develop that
Bishop in C8
so black decided to capture and now the
screen will kind of wander around for a
little bit going back to B3
I5 Castle a for this is still Theory are
not
I don't know if this is interesting
actually
because yes you have given yourself
quite a lot of space on the queen side
but
now you're kind of stuck with a pawning
C6 to protect B5 unless you manage to
keep pushing them forward
I could be totally wrong but
the opponent C6
if it gets stabilized it's gonna be bad
for black
Bishop D2 and Knight C5
okay
uh Fidel is still playing as if he's
comfortable with that position I guess
but
what do you think
you know it's an interesting setup I
mean blacks gained some space and
there's always some risk when you're
pushing pawns early and creating
weaknesses but also you've gained space
so white needs to do something concrete
to prove that it's an incorrect strategy
and really this position transposed into
lines similar to where white plays Queen
B3 will move forward against the slob
and black can fan cattle in those lines
and again I think they're they're very
playable and you can get all three
results in these positions I I would be
a little concerned as black with that
Knight on C5 because
you know what white has a pretty firm
grip on that square but typically the
problem for black is if the bishop is
stuck on B7 behind that C6 pawn and in
this particular position it's not but on
the long term basis you know white has
that Bishop on G2 that's hitting that
weakness on C6 and so if you know black
trades the bishop say on G4 because he
can't find a good Square far after white
say plays H3 because he's running into
the problem of potentially E4 so you're
saying this yeah yeah I'm just saying
strategically you know black is sitting
there at that pawn on C6 and you know
when you're playing the cavalin or
something like that you you want that
white squared Bishop you have targets to
attack and you've got a target with no
counterpart I agree I remember when I
was a kid I conscious family of you who
don't know and
I have a sister and my parents told her
this that to play the Catalan with white
I think she still plays it with good
results although she kind of stopped
playing chess she just plays
occasionally some team competitions but
um that was the Catalan Bishop you know
that was the bishop that you never want
to trade and
um and the King's Indian sometimes maybe
you do want to trade this bishop if it
gets to be one of those Advanced
variations where you get your Bishop out
and traded but typically you know this
bishop if it ever gets open same for for
blacks one in some situations that's
you know your your diamond your you know
your your biggest treasure that you need
to have there very well protected so
yeah and that Bishop can be very
dangerous and that's why I did not like
as soon as I saw those pawns push
personally I did not like it I mean of
course I
um
am not a Kings Indian player so
um or grunfeld player so so in those
kinds of positions sometimes you you do
end up having some kind of weaknesses
but this turned out into something
completely different it's more
positional and
I'm very much
betting on white I'd rather have white
here unless these ideas with E5 I think
those are some ideas that black could
try to con consider so that in some way
we undermined this Knight there
to offer some trades and then undermine
this Pawn so that we start and somehow
can push if something like that could
happen for black then maybe he's having
an okay position but just going for for
tactics considering that tactics are
important that could be some idea to con
right but black has to try that and
really it and I think to your point on
the trade so if black plays E5 and and
white say plays D takes Knight takes
Knight takes and Bishop takes then you
have that pawn on B2 which the the
bishop on G7 is hitting but at the same
time when you trade that Knight on D7
for the Knight on F3 for example you
can't rid yourself the Knight on C5 so
we could come back we could come back
and try to chase it it was the other
night yeah with this other knife but but
I would be happy if I would open up my
Bishop too since we do have some kind of
symmetry here definitely symmetry just
you know on these files and maybe you
know an idea here is that play E5 after
you play Bishop takes F3 with the idea
that if D takes Knight takes the Knight
can slip into C4 when all of a sudden
the Knight on C5 is loose so maybe
that's an idea
black here so strategically I think this
position is tough for black but they're
certainly some tactical yeah sometimes
some tactical ideas that may make this a
little bit hard for a white to really
yeah I think if we could somehow get the
Knight to E5 and maybe play F4
that could be we're weakening something
as well we're Reckoning the E3 Pawn but
then I would get the Knight here to
Super
you know to Super protect my 19 C5 and
and try to to find more ways to
bring additional pressure maybe I'm just
talking too much here about this F4 push
but
um I guess I'm just a huge fan of
pillsbury's idea with F4 even wrote an
article about it so who knows yeah it's
an interesting position
um someone said hi to me that we played
in round two of the Southwest class I
remember you you played an extremely
strong game against me and um welcome to
the chat welcome yeah and thank you
everyone who's watching both on
Twitch and YouTube and feel free to
tweet us tweet tweet the club's page if
you have any specific questions don't
forget in a few days we are going to
have great tournament starting here at
the American Cup and
of course that will be broadcast in life
and
it will be they'll be commentary by some
of your favorites we will have I think a
preview of that once we take a break too
so
um yeah March 17 till 26th
some of the strongest players in the
country will be playing so there's a
very interesting uh system system the
way the tournament is the the format of
the tournament I think right yeah
someone in the chat's in this position
they're considering 91 Knight D3 which
is a great idea but you have the issue
of The Rook on F1 yeah and so
strategically this is an interesting
position I mean black like I said has
created a lot of weaknesses but he has
space so
if you could play 91 Knight D3 it would
be fantastic but there's the Tactical
issue and
well this this is a thing it's
completely out of out of crazy out of
mind to do this but we have an idea that
is uh how do you capture back of the
Queen
probably with the queen and then the
idea would be to go here and then try to
get this Knight there that way similar
to the idea that one of our followers is
mentioning however I don't think
so sometimes black can give up that
Bishop for this Pawn structure because
white doesn't have a great attack it
looks ugly
but now all of a sudden you freed that
majority on the queen side to go forward
with c5b4 and you did but what about
your king if I can if you get this
movement maybe it'll be fine you should
be able to get them moving well
yeah there's going to be the idea of the
default too because we got that Outpost
so if you'll move the Knight then you
know there's always pluses and minuses
that you have to really wait in very
very well
um obviously
um
is there another option for black here
well the The Bishop's awkward I I might
have made an error by saying Queen yeah
maybe bishop takes maybe bishop takes
but still
um is there an option to come here
I can't play e
for because you're going to my idea is
just to weaken you to attract you to
make some weaknesses so that after that
you can't move the night because that
bomb will be so but I forged you so no
but I thought I had you have a trick so
[Music]
yeah yeah does it work
do you have something in between I don't
think I have an in-between move on night
takes here is an in between move but um
does it work
you still remain pinned
but you still have that
and it's a very messy situation
this looks good for white yeah I've got
everything covered it does
um
okay well
I guess that doesn't work I was being a
little bit over optimistic which is okay
because we're analyzing we're allowed
yeah right and I think this you know
points out that strategically this
position is potentially very difficult
here for black because there's no easy
way to resolve these issues and Knight
takes C5 is a fascinating idea to give
up what appears to be a dominant night
but just to reduce the counter play with
E5
and we'll have to see how that game
develops we're going to take a short
break here and um
we'll come back with some very exciting
chess this afternoon thanks for staying
with us
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined 300 thousand dollars in prizes
we will cover all the action live from
the World Chess Hall of Fame from March
17th through March 26th tune in for the
best game in chess streaming live for
more information visit uschesschamps.com
thank you
[Music]
boom
s
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to commentary of round five
before the break we had we went over a
few of the top games and there were some
very interesting positions and we
thought we'll get you started directly
with one where we thought some
interesting things were happening and
that was the game between
you in this position we believe that
Queen E7 was the move that had to be
played by black with potentially
attempting to Castle long or just you
know just kind of deal with the threat
the white head taking advantage of the
pin of the bishop in E6 and the Knight
was hanging and it was somehow difficult
to imagine where the Knight would go
otherwise of course the bishop E6 would
be hanging and then this bishop couldn't
go to E7 we thought because of the loss
of the pawn but it seems like
Christopher decided to play that move he
did and the game progressed similar to
what we thought where you know white
would just grabbed the pawn after
trading some pieces
and Christopher is playing this position
where he has a pawn down at the moment
but he might have thought that you know
he he has some compensation for it with
that Bishops getting traded now
um white is going to have some
weaknesses on the dark Square so it
might not be so easy to
to figure out how to cover those
mihail decided to go C3 here to cover
those dark squares obviously if you're
going to Castle long some ideas with
queen
F6 could could appear and the Knight
coming to B4 and maybe he was feeling
uncomfortable about this
so he decided to go for C3 Queen F6 was
played anyways and now Queen E3 so what
is the idea here if we take the pawn you
may ask and
I don't have an answer just yet maybe
maybe white was just planning on
castling and playing Rook C1 and saying
you've got a weed Pawn on C5 and and the
king in the center and the King's in the
center and you know if black plays say
B6 to support that pawn
there's more weaknesses there
maybe still Roxy one
and Quinn would have to
I guess the queen could stay around here
as well
is it possible that we could actually
use the other Rook to go Rook C1 and try
to
somehow trap a queen if it worked the
same B2
I don't quite see a way yeah I don't
think you're gonna trap it because the
diagonal is going to stay open
because I was thinking for wide
potential ideas with uh with D4 and
um trying to open up the position but do
they work
Pawn takes and then Queen somewhere
yeah I was a little surprised that white
played C3 there
um a little bit too soon because
when you play C3 you've now committed
your king to the king side and you've
created upon weakness and if you didn't
want to Castle kingside to begin with
okay you had to go to the queen side so
maybe Christopher is right in terms of
his judgment it's sacrificing upon here
is correct we can see the computer
evaluation was saying that white was a
little bit better immediately after
sacrificing the pawn but now we can see
that it's suggesting that black is
actually a little bit better after
playing C3
so that's right it's a interesting
choice by white to create that weakness
there and it does look a little risky to
Castle kingside
I just wanted to make an announcement I
believe we already have a result on game
one
um Nicolas Drew against
they we stopped around here
and how did that because that was an
important game for the standings that
just the result just came looks like
they didn't okay we thought white would
have some chances here right because of
the isolated Pawn right but I think this
is Theory there's still this is a long
theoretical line and okay now and now
we're trading queens and getting into an
office right and white wasn't very
ambitious yeah he was not quite this
here maybe he got a little bit tired
having had so many tough games
um he won yesterday as you mentioned
earlier he won first he won against
darshwirtz and then in the afternoon he
won against Fidel Corrales right so he
had a very tough day yesterday maybe he
thought he would go for a
last night in the game that he played it
and anybody that likes to see a very
sharp short attacking game between GM
should check out uh the fourth round
game that Nicholas played yesterday he
played absolutely tremendous just
yesterday Nicholas with his win over
Darius which is a textbook example of
how to play a long-term attack with the
pawn on H6 it absolutely should look at
those games just fantastic change I
agree I agree that was there's
definitely a great game that I'm Gonna
Save for my own file
um potentially teaching
um anyways let's go back to that game
just wanted to bring you up to speed
with a result that just happened so
um after C3 Christopher did play Queen
F6 and now Queen E3 I guess Mikhail
decided that their
was not sufficient time to protect the
pony C3 with Rook C1 for some reason
why
yeah I I'm really surprised that black
didn't capture the pawn on C3 yeah
Christopher went for long Castle first
maybe he thinks he can capture anyways
because you see with the queen in E3 uh
like Queen E3 is going for C5 though
because I was about to say we have ideas
and some Bishop H3 and things but can
white not be greedy and just take that
pawn
um is there some Bishop G4
or maybe rookie 8 first
Bishop G4 seems implies and maybe that's
it
foreign
you're threatening a piece and you're
threatening a check so the white king is
now stuck in the middle it is yeah and
for example if you say well I'm gonna go
94 and put on some pressure sure you
will which Rook are we going to use
um maybe this one
you have to go here and there's going to
be another check coming up
and some mates
are definitely some mating that is is
being prepared
I do not see a specific way to it just
yet
but I'm sure it's there well you have a
weak back rank here you do F2 is weak
weak back rank g2s made you might even
be able to just play Queen E7 here which
is threatening Queenie one Shack now
white can put a knight on F3 so that may
not quite work but
it looks dangerous because how do you
ever get the Rook on h1n yeah this this
Rook is totally restricted I mean there
are some ways if you give me a couple of
moves for example like you said Queen E7
I would trade and then I would try to
see if I could get this pump pushed so
that I can play King F2 of course I
don't have time because you would double
up and
um and get major but I I do have a way
right I'm sorry I wouldn't have traded
Queen Sarah yes suggesting that as
potentially yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah to
get there I mean you also hit
five as well yeah yeah yeah so no I was
just trying to show the audience that
um if you're not careful a little bit
white does have a few ways to escape
here so you need to be mindful a little
bit that's why I was debating which Rook
to put because maybe it would help to
have this one still here keeping that
protected or maybe even get Rook D6 to
keep to keep
the queen side and my king covered
before I I do any kind of attacks but
yeah but it's still a little surprising
to me though that black didn't take off
the uh the C3 Pawn you know going back a
couple moves here because again it
weakens the pawn structure
um for white because he no longer has
control of the D4 Square anyway shape or
form
it still looks somewhat problematic to
Castle kingside because I can always go
Queen side if I want is black and here
we're looking at at B6
and I don't really see a way to attack
to attack the to play D4 I really would
love to play D4 or B4 with white but I
I have to be very
very aggressive to get some
some activity now I mean white could
play from Knight to G5 here
because you know you no longer have
control the G5 score at the queen of C3
can Retreat all the time
um we can go back here and maybe get
this other night
obviously capturing would leave the
Night Trap there after Queen G6 I
believe
so you couldn't do that but
before you take I'm thinking maybe we
can we can bring an additional piece to
the attack and black would have to
choose where to place their King
I know this might be a little bit of an
ambitious choice but I think I should be
fine with black so someone was
suggesting Queen F4 instead of
um here
right instead of maybe Knight G5
you know you have a potential Invasion
Square on D6 where you know the night's
loose
but if black castles
that points won't be able to get
to get that actor in a way so yeah I I
mean again this is one of those
positions where we could be completely
wrong since we're not looking at this
with a computer I I guess my view was is
when I take that pawn on C3 I I created
sort of weaknesses that white can never
get rid of in his position so if white
doesn't have something tactically here
long term I've won the game it's black
yeah and
um whereas if I don't take the pawn now
we might also be very good after Queen
takes C5 Bishop H3 or the check and
Bishop H3 that we are looking at because
the white king is stuck
well you always saying this position is
better for white and it's not I'm
actually curious what the engine thinks
just for a moment here
um about so it says Castle is the best
move in this position yep and queen
takes seats so which what did it give
there it gives so C3 was uh definitely
not a choice of the engine Castle was
the move as we suggested but actually
Shore Castle not long right interesting
I would think the king would be weak
here as well as it is there but maybe
because black already has the pawns
pushed
you want to Castle short instead of long
yeah and what does the computer give
against Queen takes C3 there's a couple
people are saying they would have played
it and there's a little bit of
controversy about that move here so so
after Queen E3 Queen takes C3 it says
quite balanced actually Castle as we
said B6 Rook a to C1
um pretty much our line and this is
Queen back to F6 and then yes this idea
the dimension was b or D4 but the admin
the advantage that white has is minimal
and it will go soon to zero it goes to
zero but but on the other hand you know
Black's King is now stuck in the middle
after D4 so that that would be
um
potentially why probably why Christopher
didn't play it is he was concerned about
his long-term King safety here that he
didn't know where he could put his King
in ever feel safe that's good
uh these positions are tough to play
this has been a game where the players
have had some very difficult choices
pretty early on in the game in terms of
where to put their pieces
so Christopher ended up castling and we
are in this position where it seems that
our line that we suggested quintake C5
is not a good move exactly because of
Bishop G4 Knight D4 Rook E8
and this line oh look at this move that
the engine is suggesting in Rook to G4
and trying to get rid of
I don't know what it tries to get rid of
well it's probably trying to play Rook
takes D4 and then Rook E2 with the idea
Queen F3
that's a nice kind of idea you
definitely want to you have you want to
have that idea
as I was mentioning Christopher is
someone who loves puzzles and he loves
sort of tactical motifs so this is the
kind of thing that Christopher is going
to excel in is to find an idea like that
so interesting game I think we'll see
what happens
yes let's move over to some of the other
games unless we had any questions coming
in from the chat that we want to address
[Music]
um
I think they've covered that why don't
we go back to vars game and not the
tremendous amount has happened here but
um we left it off just before here like
at castles I think yeah
here after Castle we were talking about
potential struggles that black would
have with the bishoping C8 not being so
clear where it's going to go but Bishop
D7 was played Bishop F3 Queen B6
and now VAR went for 94. this is an
interesting choice so I guess
he thought he would start challenging
that placement of the queen in B6 before
bringing his Rooks on the opened CND
files so here number 984 obviously with
black you don't want to give up your
Bishop although it's a bad Bishop you're
struggling with it you don't want to
give it up I think that would not have
been something yeah I think it's
interesting because Dennis didn't want
to end up with a weak Pawn on C6 and
when he played Queen B6 he's now
threatened to neutralize everything by
playing say Knight C6 with the idea
Bishop C6 so bar has to be quick
you know to avoid black neutralizing and
if black trades the bishop then we've
got the Catalan Bishop you know coming
down the diagonal with the target that's
right
it's not much it's not much but it's a
tiny advantage that you're going to try
to grind grind your opponent with that
tiny little bit of advantage that you
have and uh
so looks like Dennis is trying to create
some kind of
um complications after Queen C5
doesn't want to trade probably it
wouldn't work
because after Knight takes it's
difficult to protect both of those
pieces so you have to take an A4 which
I'm sure is something he calculated
before he went for that move and now
Queen takes E7
and that Queen is not going to be
trapped anytime soon goes back
potentially to G3 and try to put some
pressure there
I think
I I think bar is trying to pressurize
the B7 pawn and he's focusing on the
fact that the bishop on D7 can't easily
get to C6 in the play Black played E5
here that's usually a very very very
committal move so you have to be very
careful when you play it to make sure
you're not going to lose the pawn and
that this move is going to be possible
as well in my opinion
what do we do now probably might be
three dealing
I would have loved to place the night
there but now we have this idea that
some pleasant do you think E4 is
something that Danish has considered or
will consider probably
goes back
and
whom do we like here
you know
I'm trying to remember who wrote the
book I think it was Yvonne sakalov you
know wrote a positional book where he
gave this structure where with that pawn
on e4 if the black Bishop is behind it
and white has the D4 Square he has a
constant positional plus here because
white has squares for his pieces and
black always has this weak Pawn on e4 I
mean Black's not cramping white such
that he's going to get a king-site
attack here likely I mean maybe
the black pieces can swing around but I
don't really understand how the the
black queen is going to swing to the
king side here so so white is always
operating on these squares with you know
Rook fd1 Rook D4 Queen C7 and and
putting pressure I I I would think the
computer would say this is relatively
balanced but white has squares to work
on with a Target yeah that's why you
have to be careful when you push that
pawn forward too much because suddenly
that pawn is going to be a Target this
is going to be one of the targets
someone says black is winning here with
E5 double X Glam and then Rook 88 so if
we are wrong about this okay
um is the queen trapped or something the
Queen always has a retreat it's possible
they're using the engines we're trying
to avoid it unless we're letting you
know ahead but maybe they're right okay
uh
or maybe maybe Patrick is a is a Danish
fan Danish Borge fan
um okay Rook d8
I don't think that Queen is trapped no
it's not trapped but
um
I didn't always go back I have a lot of
retreat squares I even can play Rook D1
uh
if we're wrong Patrick we apologize
um
no we're not okay he he he's trolling us
a little bit Yeah okay
he just likes the black position here
okay that's okay that's okay
um Okay so
yeah I mean this this looks like a
typical position where
yeah and I think your move Rook fd1 is
also probably a pretty good idea I think
you could give up the queen for two
Rooks in this type of position yes yes
yes yes yes I think that's that's
totally fine
um
I just wasn't 100 sure because depending
on whether they have some kind of
Discovery to somehow get something else
in return
um like here here
I guess we do have 90s oh maybe not we
haven't because if Queen A5 I have
Knight takes E6 guards The Rook right
right so we're good so we're good
extract myself out of there with my two
Rooks yeah we'll Escape
um he's saying after Knight C5 there's
queen queen B5 or queen before Queen
before okay but how does this lead to a
win always we have this move right
Knight takes B7
protect attack defend
everything
is happening here for white and I think
we got nothing to worry about oh let's
not forget the most important Arrow
which is The Rook is attacked as well so
if you're taking B2 we will be very
gladly capturing the exchange and
feeling happy so no I don't think uh I
don't think this is a winning move it's
certainly a more aggressive move and
gives black some ideas but
you have to be mindful too once again as
we said if you push
if you push too many pawns forward
you're creating some weaknesses I think
more that this E5 move for for Danish is
to get this bishop out the only problem
is
does he not care about the pawn in B7
and maybe he doesn't maybe he can you
know Play Bishop to E6 right away with
the idea that you can't take on E5
because and if you take on B7 I'm going
to put my Rook on B8 and I'm going to
have pressure on the B file and I'll
regain the pawn and liquidate maybe
that's the idea
but um is this something to be worried
about
yeah of course 26 only
26 only move and then
and then I I I'm trying to be aggressive
no and and black maybe doesn't have to
play Bishop E6 right away no no right I
think you know the point is is that
might be but you're right immediately
the Pawn's under attack and Knight C5 is
an immediate threat
it isn't unpleasantly
unpleasant can you play Rook AB8 here
with going back to the idea that Patrick
pointed out Knight C5 and then Queen B4
because
but you can't because you have a pin and
I'm not taking on it I think I can
possibly play here and then take I I
don't think you have a good movement for
I think you have to go Queen B5 to keep
your Bishop protected right right it
looks really awkward it does not look
very good it does not look very good for
black I mean yes that Queen White has to
be careful with the queen not to get it
uh attacked way too many times but
maybe three is natural I'm surprised
that we have not seen a move just yet
this is the current position it seems
like far is still thinking here
about where to move the Knight but he
doesn't have many options so what
exactly is he thinking about yeah that's
surprising maybe there was an offer a
draw offer it is possible that is
something we never have access to so we
we wouldn't be able to bring that to you
yeah I mean I'm a little surprised he's
thinking too so long because the only
other square is really 92 with the idea
of Knight C3 but yeah but maybe 92 is an
option but Knight B3 with the idea of
Knight C5 and also it keeps the the
black queen from hitting the D1 Square
in some lines or you put your Rook on D1
and black puts his Rook on d8 right
right so it seems the most natural
Square to put the night I guess we'll
we'll have to wait and see
more moves let's hope we're not having
technical difficulties with the
transmission of the light of the games
live let's go back to Christopher's game
here because
so for those of you who have joined us
later on board one we already had a draw
between Nicolas theodoro and quesada
Perez yeser that's why we're now going
on board one we're not going back to
that game we have shown the game and
didn't draw no more moves
came onto this game either
so we're still at at long Castle I I
will refresh the page just in case
sorry about that
um but yeah nothing nothing is going on
in that game we had a couple more moves
happening in this game and this is
actually getting a little bit
interesting we stopped here after Bishop
B7
and we were talking about white
potentially pushing C4 at some point but
he wasn't rushing but how exactly is he
going to
palacious pieces so darrish played 92.
and after Knight G6 which we kind of
anticipated because that pawn doesn't
have sufficient protection by another
Pawn or or the bishop 96 and now G3
always the the nice kind of idea where
we're restricting the Knight on the the
edge of the board and then
um
Queen D5 C4 and now Queen to D7
was played that's interesting that black
actually decided to go here to attract
C4 I thought
that should be good for a while to play
that move
so or maybe not because now that's a
weakness that black can take advantage
of in a way when the bishop will go to
G2 so maybe he just you know you would
think oh let's just go Queen D7 directly
because
it's normal we need to develop but no he
played here because obviously because of
the diagonal it was
um and of course the pressure on the
pawn in E5 it was kind of anticipated
that white would go C4 so black is
getting something out of this although
it seems like he's not Queen D7 Queen to
E2 long castle and now H4
okay
so
this is another kind of move that you
see when you realize we got opposite
side castling
you are typically expecting that white
is going to rush with the attack on the
queen side and definitely not make any
more moves
pawn moves especially on the king side
since
his King will end up being weak and that
Bishop is all open so I'm really really
surprised of this move H4 what do you
think
it's typical you know there's a
variation in the king's Indian attack
where black plays B6 on move seven
instead of B5 the transposers and the
position is very similar in white plays
C4 and white is playing for a space
advantage on the king side
no black can Castle long in those
possessions and it's it's dangerous for
both sides
I I think this position is very
double-edged here
it is so I mean it would be scary for me
to play H4 I got to tell you unless this
move has some kind of issue so either
play this or go for A3 B4
yeah I think you know what black is
suggesting here is is that when you play
a3b4 I'm going to take your pawn and I'm
going to be able to cover the pawns on
the queen side it's very dangerous it's
very double-edged
because you're Pro you're having
protected and then I'm going to come
back to playing h5h4 against your king
and I've got my Bishop on the diagonal
so white is just getting ready for for
Black's H5 so he just um
psychologically reverse psychology or
something he's just saying I'm gonna
weaken making let's see how you're gonna
be able to open it up that that kind of
okay sure and there have been some moves
in the Christian for woo game here I I
believe I refresh my screen over here so
oh it was I did not see anything new
nope there's no new there's no new move
this is the final position that's
interesting let me
see if you look at the screen here yeah
I understand but the you're seeing mine
as our analysis it's still there okay
sorry yeah
um so you would see if there's an okay
now now it's refreshed now it did
refresh
oh they actually went for our line well
they didn't go for our line that there's
something they played Queen E7 which is
the move I had originally suggested that
we reject it because this is where
Christopher had Rook to G4 which you
know we saw was probably winning for
black
so we had all this line played except
this is if you go back except yeah
except this is where there was this
spectacular movement
the double Rook sacrifice and then made
on G2 and I think we decided this was
probably winning for black and it looks
like Christopher missed that opportunity
um
that was really good I think if we turn
on the engine for a moment it says -2 in
this position after Rook G4
but a queen E7 I don't know if that's
I yeah because you had suggested I I
suggested that as an idea to try and get
to the back rank not necessarily in that
position to play it because right right
between trade I'm surprised he's going
for the queen trade because I think he
enjoys attacks a lot maybe he maybe he
saw something we did not see and you
know it's very surprising here how much
time Christopher has left on his clock
because again if we go back to right
before he played Queen E7 this is one of
those positions where you'd say this is
kind of a critical moment here
um the the white Rook is trapped
potentially Forever on on H1 I mean
White's going to have to be able to play
F3 King F2 to get it out someday and if
you're sitting here with the black
pieces you have all of your pieces ready
they're all on the right squares to to
make something happen and it's hard to
strengthen your your position more yeah
so when you have that situation you have
to figure out how do I break through the
moment is right now
and and with him having an hour still on
the clock I mean Christopher should have
really invested some time in this
position to try and find a way to break
through here because the position is
sort of crying out for it that White's
playing a rook down and White's not
fully developed so can you force your
way to the F3 Square
and and there is a way as we're pointing
out to remove both of the white Knights
Rook G4 first takes on D4 and then Rook
E2 and take on D2 and and queen F3 in
its Checkmate yeah that would have been
a
nice idea for him
is he giving up completely the advantage
after Queen E7 he could be worse because
he's also a pawn down
so the Knight is
well white is still kind of stuck here
so I'm I'm pretty sure this should be
the next move for black just to make
sure that the Knight is not going to be
able to move away from there because of
the back rank
but can white do something like Knight
F1 1993
yeah it's still hard for white to
untangle so when I say white could be
worse it's probably you know it would be
shocking if White's worse but right you
have Knight G5 as you're pointing out to
chase the bishop in some lines I think
white play Knight F1 if I'm not mistaken
95 was played 95 was played in this
position
it does not it does not refresh to me
immediately so um
okay I supposedly get it to people I I
think that's the current position that I
have right now is with 95 yes yes this
is what we have at the moment
yeah and maybe this is still very good
for black I mean it's very hard for
white to untangle that Rook there
right one of the readers is saying why
can't you know black just play rookie
seven double on the e-file and keep
Queens on the board and for some sort of
zugsling and that that was another plan
as well but I I think what we're
suggesting is this Rook to G4 move here
is very forcing and the threat is simply
Rook takes D4 and it's very very hard to
find an answer for black hair
and I I don't like if you play Queen
takes say D5 here you've given up the
pin and then you know black I think can
just play Knight takes D4 here
and um
you know you have to take with us sorry
and now
rookie two
I have one check yeah one check and
that's about it
no more checks researching mate
oh is this an option
this might be an option for oh hold on I
can play Queen to E7
I have a small thread
it's not as easy as it looks but easy it
it's not easy nothing is easy maybe we
have this idea of cleaning hold on I I
may be able to just play Rook takes the
Rook on G takes E4 and then take on e4
again I'm still threatening the back
rank mate yeah but I'll just oh you want
to take the Rook the g-rook yeah yeah
but when I take it okay it takes E4 and
then I'm still threatening the
background but but I have Queen C3 in
that case so I might be able to hold on
but I think you should be able to bring
in the queen much faster here maybe you
can go queen queen C7 in this position
and
this Rook has to move somewhere and then
the queen can King come in and have all
those threads I don't think they're
going anywhere
um
this this is not going to be a position
for white to survive necessarily but of
course you know there could still be
some some defenses some defensive
I'd be shocked if White's surviving
after Queen takes day five I mean yeah
sure there shouldn't be a survival here
we we probably could could try even
other things in this position yeah
yeah maybe now Queen E7
but then there's potentially that check
to trade
just this decision as you said of
trading the Queens does not seem ideal
for black
it's true that the Rook is stuck here
but there could often be ideas to escape
from that so you wouldn't really want to
um
right but but it's still a difficult
position for white when you look at it
still very difficult to extract um The
Rook even when the the Queens came up
but that's certainly an interesting
position if we go back to darius's game
he has executed the idea I suggested of
you know gaining space with h4h5
and
these are interesting positions here
um you know black plate H6 now
and
you know black can't expand on the queen
side so so White's eventually going to
build up this attack Sabina was
referring to with A3 B4 Bishop D2 put
the E Rook on B1 and aim all the Rooks
of the black king and and black has to
try and um
you know do a similar thing to to White
by playing G6 but when you do that
you've you've weakened the
um F6 square and if you stick a knight
in there and sometimes if you trade that
black squared Bishop now you've made
your king much more vulnerable on the
queen side because the bishop can come
to F4 in some lines
but H3 uh sorry H6 was necessary for
black to play because otherwise if you
play G6 most likely I do a Lancer like
this yes and then Black's way of opening
up the king side has reduced to playing
F6 which typically doesn't really help
as much and I don't even know how you do
it because obviously now you're losing
some material and if you're not ready to
recapture it
it's going to be an issue so H6 is a
very important move for black to play
that's why in this position
um after after each five night there
he decided to go for H6
right and typically I I've had similar
positions to this but my knight was on
D7 and my queen was on C7 and that would
be sort of a but the move order was
different right that's what I was kind
of saying earlier about the positions
that I'm playing myself here the Knight
goes either that way or oftentimes it
ends up going into C7 that way so so
this seems worse to me for black than
the positions I'm familiar with because
in those positions white has to guard
that pawn on E5 because you've got three
pieces hitting it yeah whereas in this
position black doesn't have that
pressure yeah he's behind he's still in
these two moves Queen c797 to actually
reach the pawn and tried to get it and
um white might just end up just giving
it up or
maybe still defending it a little bit of
a bishop F4 and just maintaining the the
pin on the Knight that's going to
capture and then you might not even be
able to take it because this Knight
would Retreat and you would use your
piece in E5
so it's it's a little bit tricky so
Bishop Bishop G2 was played in this
position
um so this is this is what we currently
have any other changes let's see I think
the varging has changed and something
has happened here this got tricky for
white all of a sudden he played Knight
B3 and then Bishop B5
maybe this is what he was worried about
Rook D1 and now E4 wait Rook D1
oh
yeah now where's Barb with the bishop
well he has Rook D4 right D4
um Queen A6
and then Bishop D1 I guess
I don't know should we trade should we
not trade does that matter should we let
black
be the one capturing
the only thing I don't like is that if
we regardless whether we take or not
Black's next move is going to be after
the Queens get traded rook d8 and then
the Rook might get
somehow active obviously not there maybe
here or just just active on the defile
that's going to be something hard to to
meet yeah Bishop B5 was a good move
there for black and you know we missed
that in our analysis when we were
looking at this position
but wasn't wasn't this still an option
for right first or
yeah well we looked at similar lines but
I don't think yeah we didn't know we
looked at the age we looked at rook d8
and then Knight C5 was coming Knight
takes B7 hitting the rook in V8 when the
bishop was there
but in this situation seems like
an option for white as well I think but
my Rook is hanging on F1
not yet because you know you need to I
need to move the queen
maybe you want to go on this other side
of the board
I'm kind of worried if you stay here I
want to play A3 and you know you won't
be able to take here because now I'm
escaping with the Rook from the attack
with temple
so
[Music]
um
like but far didn't play that no no he
play look after D1 and then
um black played E4 and now he's thinking
now we got this position he's thinking
right but I mean it looks like Rook to
D4 is forced or otherwise you've you've
is the other option here for right
and uh because because this has blocked
the Queen's exit over there so
um
depending on I I think this might be a
slightly better option for Roy because
it doesn't allow the trading of the
Queens I don't think white wants to
trade Queens in this position
so I feel that you should try to hold on
to them as much as possible
now if that is really possible we don't
know yet so let's just say here
now we still cannot go Rook D4 because
then they would take this Rook would be
hanging in the bishop so let's play A3
and a few takes
I was thinking well
yeah I think Rook DB1 makes sense
now you got to figure out where the
queen goes because you're well you could
also try to offer a trained
but
and now we have to trade I don't really
have much
much saying that but but but no
two pieces are hanging do we go for this
line maybe we could go for it
that he's gonna take and who's better
and why
at least the position has changes
and black looks okay because you've got
to really guard probably the rook and
then black can play B6 and you take on
G2 and Black's the pawn up there so
so this looks very okay to me for blacks
so
yeah so maybe I've made a mistake for
for like here somewhere
or maybe we simply cannot cannot afford
to go Knight C5 we it seems that we kind
of have to go for this move because
um because
the bishop is hanging so we didn't move
the rook and as I showed if we go here
he takes and we don't have a way to
escape with either one of you our pieces
from the attackwood temple
so this line is forcing and if it's not
a good kind of forcing then you just
lose something
maybe this other look to be one
but then you know yeah what stops the
black from getting it right right
um yeah this this is a little bit scary
um they he did looks like vardy play
Rook D4 Queen A6 was played and the
Queens got traded so we might go for
um
we might see potentially some kind of a
Bishop D1 is probably going to be next
the next move being played by VAR
and um yeah but black seems totally fine
to me here because you know Dennis has
his Bishop you know outside the pawn and
can put it on D3 in some cases
but
yeah and it's hard for white to bring
his King into the game to get to the um
the pawn maybe he can play G4 King G2
King g3 at some point but black can
always play G5 too if you do that yeah
it's not going to be easy to reach dip
on I mean definitely Rook C1 Bishop here
are some ideas for why 95 trying to
support that Knight there take advantage
because this bishop is potentially
slightly better than White's Bishop but
in the same time it is a little bit
exposed and kind of has to stay to
protect the B7 so if black plays B6
maybe they'll be fine
this remains to be seen But I suggest we
take a short break and we'll be back
with you shortly it's pretty close thank
you
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chest capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
[Music]
thank you
welcome back on feeding Master Doug
Eckert and I'm here with women's
great to be back
um it seems that on tweak twitch
leadership we had a raid we missed it I
do not know whom that rate is for but
from but thank you very much Raiders
welcome
um you are watching commentary of the
San Luis super Swiss event and before
the break we were looking at bars
game and before that we're looking at
this game of Christopher you where he
missed potentially an interesting
opportunity of trying to check my tease
opponent on the back rank instead
he decided to go for
that that move was Rook G4 and the idea
was to try to give up both of his Rooks
in order to be able to either get his
opponent on the weakness of G2 or
potentially back rank depending on what
moves white was going to do instead he
decided to go for this end game that we
were not so sure with Doug whether it
was totally winning or not but
it appears that black is winning we
looked at it very briefly with the
engine here and again white is playing a
rook down here and as we go through the
next several moves you'll see that um
white wasn't able to extricate himself
from the um the jam that he was in here
so Knight G4 is playing
he tried the trade of the night I guess
92 probably wasn't going to to do very
much because of a potential entrance
with the Rook it looks like it so if you
play rookie 2 and then um
don't think that's the most I'm not
gonna work there hmm
I don't think this is gonna lead
although we could be fancy right right
but also you might even be able to play
Bishop takes G2 before rookie two so at
the Knight on G4
I just I wouldn't want to I mean we can
always get that right I think this is
just gonna be crushing for black there's
no no defense we're being right right I
would never I was saying before you put
the Rook down you might even just be
able to play Bishop takes G2 and rookie
two and um oops Yeah rookie two here and
it's very very difficult here for white
three
yes and then I play Knight takes F2
yeah this Rook will will not survive
this attack right I'm thinking after
Rook G1 I can play Knight to
H3 and then if you have to go back I can
play H5 and don't I have your king in a
mating net yep
I I think black White's truck made it
here
it's going to be a nice kind of chicken
but uh going back to the game white
decided to make some trades to trade
some pieces but unfortunately it wasn't
it doesn't seem that it was sufficient
either way because even if 9g2 was
possible and now we escaped a little bit
from The Mating net
Rook F3 was played I love this move this
is a really nice restrictioning move and
now this other Rook is planning on
coming to E2 and that would be very
unpleasant so I decided to go Knight to
F4 and now Christopher considering that
this Rook is strapped forever in H1 he
thought he can afford to give up the
exchange but it just seems like he's
actually playing with an extra piece
because
after rookie 2 this king is not going
anywhere and neither is this Rook so why
does totally restricted over here and
you should be able to just start
grabbing some material bringing his King
and just maybe create a postpone and win
on The Queen side
yeah it doesn't look like white really
has any moves because you know
Christopher I mentioned that he likes to
do problems he's a big fan of zoosling
positions and if you think about this
position right here white can only have
his Rook on D1 or otherwise he loses the
Rook because if he goes to see one then
white or black has Rook G2 Rook C2 check
winning The Rook so I think this is a
position that Christopher is going to
try and want run white out of moves he
can literally just let white move his
pawns forward till he runs out of pawn
moves and then he wins a rook right
right and Christopher loves Zig zoing
theme so I think that's exactly what
we're seeing here to him this is he's in
heaven he's going to let white run out
of pawn moves and win The Rook
and just move the Rook somewhere there
and then checking if one Rook here grab
the rook and win yes so that's gonna be
that's gonna be an interesting finish to
this game where we thought white was
doing much better in the beginning well
not much better but definitely better
had a much more comfortable position out
of the opening and
and uh
that's C3 that's C3 weakening move
um led to a little bit of the collapse I
think this is also a good illustration
about people often ask me why is a grand
master better than a master and I think
Christopher showed a lot of judgment in
this position to give up that G7 Pawn
that he had enough compensation and you
know now we see him 15 moves later with
just an overwhelming position and it was
very difficult for me as a lower rated
Master to see that black had sufficient
compensation there and I don't know
Sabina how you feel about that but it's
one thought that I've had over the years
oh no I I thought black was worse I
thought black was worse I didn't think
there was enough compensation in that
position at all
but but Christopher was able to find it
and prove us wrong so yes that's on
board three we've had quite a bit of
change to the position there okay yeah
it seems like black was able to follow
up with a plan that was suggested to
play G6 as for white he did end up
breaking through the position with A3
and B4 so G6 was played a three capture
now black was able to open semi-open the
G file he still has to play possibly
some H4 and try to be mindful
um that white doesn't go G4 G5 G4
against the H5 G5 something like that to
keep the G file from opening
but white is getting active on the queen
side as well capture capture and now as
you uh somehow suggested black took the
pawn
and he's trying to he's going to try to
prove the fact that he's Bishop with the
pieces that he has on the queen side
he's going to be able to hang on to the
um extra two pawns that he have right he
has right now because he took one there
and one here
and is white going to be able to
find a way to build up his attack Bishop
A3 A5 was played and of course this move
somehow has to be played because if the
Knight goes back to C6
I believe this is this is something you
know takes or Bishop D6 possibly takes
I'm thinking dude yeah I think this is
the end of the world for black hair if
all the lines come open on the queen
side so yeah so you don't want to get
into this kind of positions so A5 was
played and this idea you may have been
able to see with the reverse colors
white is doing it sometimes in a Banco
after they take the pawn in A6 they
usually end up placing one piece in B5
and they try to support it with A4 upon
in B3 and Pawn in A4 and it usually ends
up being a bishop sometimes it can be a
knight similar to how this position is
so quite a typical idea
to maintain the side of the board
yeah I have no idea what the computer
evaluation is here but I think this
position is still very double-edged with
all three results possible it's not that
easy to see how white is going to break
through on the uh the queen side
you know if you have to give up the
bishop and then sack and exchange to get
something on B4 do you have enough
material left over there to deliver a
mate maybe you do because you're going
to have the Knight on e4 to come to D6
and then you know if you can trade the
light squared Bishops maybe it's Airy
but Black's going to play Rook G8 H4 and
start loosening your king too right no I
I think I think C5 is going to be the
move to play for right here so you're
giving up a third Pawn but then somehow
once you taste maybe takes and just
enter on the a file which will get
opened I think that's that's a way for
white to go here and by pushing the C
Pawn giving up another Pawn it's true
but maybe bringing in this Knight to C4
and then
um taking advantage of some dark squares
in Black's territory I think this could
be darusha's idea I also don't know the
computer it's danger and also you know
white could maybe also drop the bishop
back to B2 and just hit the D4 Pawn
um
you know with the idea that if I can get
the D4 upon I can get to the B6 pawn and
and everything falls apart
it's a very double-edged position
um but black has to be quick I mean
blacks didn't have to play Rook G8 H4
and try and you know break through with
the idea being that if I can eliminate
the the bishop on G2
I can keep hammering away with pieces
with say you know Knight G6 hitting E5
and
even here depending on what's Happening
to this Pawn if you take for example
Knight G6 Knight F4 is going to be an
idea for black
yeah very double-edged
interesting game though
trying to see in the other games we have
not looked at ilya's game for quite a
while this is the one where Fidel pushed
all his pawns forward early in the game
and
he did achieve that idea we were talking
about that once he traded off the D4
Pawn that that made his Queen Side Pawn
majority more mobile
um
so if we go back to where we were that
pawn was stuck on C6 quite a number of
moves again yeah I was just mesmerized
by how that pawn got there because last
time we saw it we were
going back move by move slowly you see
that E5 move that I mentioned that had
to be played and Fidel just played it
immediately he doesn't have much time to
waste because if white gets the chance
to block that square then can we go back
two moves here because this is where
when white plate H3 I think you
suggested Knight takes D7 which seemed
to be kind of a strange move but we made
it effective and I'm curious what the
machine would tell us right here to see
whether or not your judgment was correct
here and yep sure enough Knight takes D7
is actually the top engine move so let's
congratulate Sabina for coming up with a
uh a very um interesting idea and that
maintained a a nice Advantage for white
but not not with this one though not
with Knight E5 it says Knight G5 here
and
um
right with the idea of H3 and then yeah
just chase the bishop away this was not
something he would have given up E5
which we talked about is a possible idea
but it seems like black is more than
fine in this position here but but still
your your idea of Knight takes D7
appears to have been the strongest idea
in the position because it made it more
difficult to get D5 yeah and this is
kind of interesting because now you're
going away from the five square but you
are having these kind of H3 threads so
for example if black Lazy Five you just
go H3 and and then you capture here and
this is going to be a little bit
different because this night after that
most likely is going to come back either
take this the shop or just go come back
to our C5
but H3 wasn't wasn't a bad decision
either just might allow black to just
equalize
and still Knight takes D7 that's the
right move yeah yeah because you kind of
get basically a very similar position to
the one we saw because now
um
we have the bishop pair so we just need
to protect H3 and then
I want you to force a weakening here
it wants you to force Awakening with
Bishop G4 and then F5 and then you can
come back and Ah that's nice
that diagonal I will have some breaks
with E4
but but um
I study I went for the trade immediately
and he did not want to get that nitrated
but I don't know this Knight seems very
unpleasant we'll stop the engine yeah we
should turn the engine off again sorry
guys
um
uh 95 we can just go back here and then
Knight C4 and
right and this was the other comment
that I made that if you allow the Knight
to come to E5 you have this Knight C4
idea where the Knight hangs on C5
and that seems to
probably come close to equalizing the
position to me it seems
I agree because now I think it's
perfectly fine now right you have to
give up that's one of the Bishops you
have to give up one of them
no you can't even you can't even move no
you could you could move back but then
you're still not holding on to your
night
he didn't take the bishop though he took
here yeah that makes sense yeah because
if you took you would destroy Your
sponsorship
and now he went back he did not trade
that's an interesting choice uh by by
Fidel because he just went back to E7
this trade probably would have delayed
black or made it maybe even impossible
to get that pawn pushing because that's
going to be hanging but by going back he
still supports the C5 push he's not
helping white get that truck into play
as it would have happened if the trade
happened
and now
before so this is how he was able to get
that C5 in yeah very creative play there
on the part of padell to get his pawns
moving forward and that's not to say
that he's equal here but he's at least
you know progressed on the side of the
board that he needs to progress on
two C4
Bishop wanted to C3 Queen C5 and as
these trades happened
um
what do we think
you know let's progress here I think to
the end of position here because they're
they're maneuvering around and yeah
white is getting the defile but it
allowed this 19 B3 now the question is
how strong that Knight is well then I
can also maneuver back to D3 as well and
just block your Rooks and you got to be
careful not to mess up and lose one of
your Rooks like one of those games that
we've seen but but white still can
oppose the Knight on D3 with the bishop
on e32 or E4 yeah so
it it's possible that White's still even
a little bit better here
but I I I as I say that I doubt it nah
I played this
possibly
yeah this is very interesting this is a
very interesting position that it it's
kind of you know difficult here for
white because you know White's Plum
majority is on the king side and if he
tries to move his paw majority forward
he's exposing his King and if we get
into an ending I'm sitting here thinking
that the best white can hope for is a
rook and four against three on the king
side and and that's probably a draw
and I I don't think that White's going
to create a mating attack in this
position
unless you can somehow force them no but
I'm I'm kind of worried a little bit you
have a weakness there about this push
yeah because the pawn in B5 is weak and
if I could somehow even trade queens and
then get one of my Rooks here the other
Rook there and you're not I haven't
decided what I want to do about the
night obviously now or
anytime soon white will have the
opportunity to take that night oh he
took it as I was saying yes as I was
saying it I feel like I have I have the
saying in Romanian language and I don't
know how it goes in English and he's
going for a good idea here with Queen
yeah okay
do you have a saying in English that's
similar to
it sounds something like your your mouth
like your tongue is
predicting things or something like that
like right you're anticipating yeah it's
intuitive that's what I think is really
yeah no but that that's we have this
like really tough saying that uh usually
you know you're anticipating bad things
but I don't know if this is better your
intuition is to warning you that there
could be a problem here yeah
yeah so It's Tricky this position is
very tricky but black doesn't have to
trade on C3 I mean he can probably allow
um
white to trade
uh of course of course you don't have to
trade but we have this threat where we
are trying to um to mess up your bone
structure which
um
yeah that's
um that's going to be
something to be worried about but
I don't know I don't know what's the
best thing can we draw this so for
example if we take take
take take
I want to be aggressive Sabina is the
aggressive kind especially towards the
end of the day or halfway through
wherever we are I think in the day am I
being too aggressive I think so because
White's gonna get back
he's gonna get back yeah you even can
pin my Rook on the back rank fine I play
Rook D1 You're Gonna Play A3 yeah
you got lucky you got them off that was
the move okay fine fine fine fine
we're going for this we're bringing our
King
no no no no no I I was being over but
you know I I think well black is okay
here
because I can't make progress as white
either
but but maybe you're right maybe if the
king gets to A4 you know
white will be much faster on the side of
the board I'm pretty sure in that line I
I don't think we can get it there
like three four yeah this this just
keeps you super restricted and then I'm
pretty sure the white is much faster in
this in this situation
[Music]
now you could have a problem
maybe I went maybe it went too fast
maybe it went too fast
okay
I thought now somebody's saying that ill
you blundered here Patrick is on the
screen so I'm not sure what's happening
in the game here
and which game in this game he's saying
ill you blunder that's the game we're
looking at I don't know where this is
the move this is this is okay we can go
back and forth and see but this is this
is the current position this is what
they have okay okay so
um
okay now now he's suggesting that that
isn't what happened
yeah Rook takes D6 and maybe your idea
works but that's a horrifically critical
decision to make here as black to play
B4 in this position I mean it's really
really hard to well what are your
passive if I get this this move in I can
only be the one playing Far Away yes
yeah
um I I think that's kind of necessary I
mean
should we check
V4 top engine mode there so again I need
to correct I'm not even spending much
does that just happens to be well no but
that's great intuition that it works um
and it makes some sense because you're
really tying white down over there and
then you're bringing your king in and
white can't ever bring his King into the
position
so you know in that position we're
looking at was say The Rook on A2 that
we're if we go all the way back to where
we were
and don't play E4 I think you have to as
white you think maybe to blinking it if
you if you bring your king all the way
across but I'll come this way unless you
come that way but then you give me this
entrance so the problem is I think I do
have to play E4 right yeah I have to
play E4 but I don't think I have to come
up to D4 like we did
but I could
I could once black reaches with the King
oops I wish I could make the arrows
correctly uh once black reaches with the
King here he protected the pawn so even
if you make it to situ then I suddenly
just yeah I know that that's a real
serious issue yeah that's that's the
problem in that position so
um
yeah it's a very interesting position
where you know
yeah
White's a pawn up and and might be
struggling in this position to hold it
and again you know it just goes to show
you that King activity in an end game is
just imperatively important
[Music]
I think there's this uh this this course
that I'm studying right now I just I
just started looking through it and and
that's that's one of the things that's
mentioned in that book
um it was by sharashevsky and I think
I think it was
the sure share scan game book
anyways
um
so I'm not sure where they're at in this
game at this point this is supposed to
be the the current position
but um yeah let's let's look at someone
else and we'll be back with this end
game and see future developments and
someone was saying that um white was
winning in the um swears game darius's
game so why don't we go back to that one
oh well white has gotten way more in
this position than we expected okay well
I definitely expected that move was
going to be played eventually but not
someone was suggesting not discussed
um
that Knight D6 was already winning here
for White and the questions coming in
hey Doug and Sabine is it easier to
calculate over the board or on a 2d
board for you and appreciate the thanks
for the commentary Sabine I'll let you
start with that one
um well I think if you want
you won't come you know player you have
to
you have to kind of learn to do both uh
well but since most uh serious games are
being played over the board you should
definitely spend a lot of time you know
setting up your positions on the board
and and doing comment and doing um
calculating on the actual board I prefer
I prefer a physical you know 3D board
but a lot of my training these days my
personal training happens on a computer
so I'm used to 2D I actually get very
dizzy if I'm setting up a 3D
um 3D pieces there's a way to set up 3D
pieces I can't do it so I either do it
on a board or 2D I can do both I'm
training both
um and I think you kind of have to
sometimes it's faster if you are able to
just do it on either on the computer or
on a book directly right I do my problem
solving and training on a board but I
found as I've gotten older I can
actually see everything on the computer
screen quicker so when we're looking at
the pieces on the board I can really see
the whole board right away whereas when
you have a real chess board in front of
you sometimes you're you're having to
move your eyes back and forth to see the
whole board so I I think I probably
actually calculate better looking at it
on a screen because I'm seeing more
stuff you know instantly when I'm seeing
it but that's just me and I think
everybody's a little bit different and
as an older player I think you know
people tend to think older players are
used to looking at things on a board and
I do a lot of studying out of books
still compared to some of my younger
colleagues but I think I do see things
better I'm looking at it on the computer
so
what so he played 96 and then after the
capture
um black didn't take back
due to
that's surprising to me but
something
due to something you're scared of which
I don't know what it was
but yeah White's actually crashing
through here I think with you know
Bishop takes b4a takes and Rook A4 and
he's going to double on the a file and
oh you want to go oh okay that's uh
that's an idea yeah black might be able
to guard some stuff but Knight D7 but I
was thinking more like just just going
here but but your idea could be
fast as well maybe that works 95 yeah
night here and thank you oh yeah you're
threatening a family for work yeah
and then
um
as well so the idea would be if you
capture after that you know
there's going to be mates directly I but
but I mean we could just double too I I
think you're right I think you're
absolutely right that's the right this
is this is this is really great because
we are having those two squares
controlled so the queen doesn't really
get to go anywhere that's hanging and
I'm just literally registering with me
yeah yeah I I just yeah that's it
but
um okay so Queen B8 was played in this
position and then Bishop takes B4
Pawn takes B4 so he thought the queen
here would help him in case of some
Knight to E5 he probably thought that
the queen would kind of cover a lot of
things I guess
but does it really
I don't know
not so sure
this also might be a position where
black white doesn't need to clean I was
going to say we're thinking the same
year and it's just over anyway because
the F7 and Rook A8 and
this Knight is a this is a beast this is
like a monster monster night right
because if you play Queen F3 you're
threatening Rook A8 mate oh okay yeah I
I was deciding which one I I would go to
F3 because that way if he takes him out
but maybe he says okay I don't know so
okay not matter let's just see so the
the threat is check and winning The Rook
right so that's our thread now is this
an option
because you know how do we mate now yeah
I can take the exchange if I want well
we can take that I can I was thinking
9c6 and Rook A7 books yeah yeah that's
what I say it's probably just me and
this is nice as I just there's so many
so many mates I think we both saw the
pattern right away White Contrary
Queen's who's this mating so this looks
nice and if if Darius wins we're we're
seeing it right now Jacob better better
bring him in foreign we're trying to get
interviews everyone but unfortunately to
our audience one of the issues when you
have a two round a day tournament is
these players have another game that
they have to play and right now that
next game starts in an hour and 45
minutes they haven't eaten so if you
think about their situation they
probably have to spend you know 45
minutes to go get something to eat
they're going to spend you know 30
minutes prepping for the next game and
that really takes a 100 percent of their
time so that's why we're struggling to
get interviews today we were hoping to
get Nicholas on you know he had a
relatively Quick Draw and he played two
does wonderful games yesterday but
unfortunately we were not able to get
him earlier today
so why don't we go back this is this is
going to be another one of those nice
games I think uh things
um I will have a lot of
I need to see if my class later today is
going to be recorded or not because if
it is then maybe I shouldn't be you know
talking about some of these games in my
lecture later tonight but if it's not
recorded maybe some people at the club
who have not had the chance to watch
these could enjoy some of these
brilliant attacking ideas so I'll find
out about that later can we go back to
Delia's game I I'm trying to see if I
refresh my board and they either did
what we suggested or if I'm I do not see
it says zero zero zero so I don't know
if you lost on time or I mean if I
refresh is going to mess up a little bit
with everything but no I don't think
he's made a move after Queen C3 we have
not received extra moves okay then why
don't we see if we can go to VAR
akobian's game we kind of focused on
that words today
go to the lower bottom
10 games
hopefully yeah this is interesting white
has snatched upon here
and he did how did so he allowed that
night huh see see I told her that
Bishop's gonna be an issue but it looks
like Dennis has saved that Bishop but
now
he had to give up his
home-minded him
he's gonna get it back he's gonna get it
back I think
um no well
you seem to disagree with me
about the recapturing okay so there he
obviously has to play Knight to B5
well or this but then there I play a
four is a problem because there's a pin
so now I want that to move so now you
could go here and there right yep yep I
agree it might be the only move yeah
well you could go A4 and give up the
pawn back because we took upon no no no
no if you play A4 black plays Rook to A8
and then you don't have a square for
your night oh
right right that's right that's right
let's show that that's a nice line
that's a nice line to show the audience
so if you go here
oopsie
oopsie that was a pin so when you take
back you lose you lose a piece
okay well that's bad
um so The Rook C2 is probably what
VAR has played uh has anticipated I mean
he hasn't played this yet to our
knowledge
and now
if we go okay there's going to be Rook
C8
that night is still really really
restricted and loose down there because
I was sitting here wondering whether you
know if black played something
or white you know can you play Knight B4
even or is that just chasing me to where
I want to go
where does it want to go C7 RC8
right but but if you go to C8 and let's
say that you trade here
and and then
you know I play you can also have the
Small Voice black you don't need to take
just yet right to let you capture and
now wherever you move the Knight will
take it oh okay
okay I missed that final move
I have to be careful this these nights
and games are always very tricky with
the night out of nowhere just
jumping around right but you can force
the Knight to see eight so so go back
here by capturing by capturing first
okay and now I I've got that Knight
down there and it like let's say if I
play Rook A6 here
to to attack the pawn but the Knight has
no Square so I'm threatening King E8
King d8 here is black
and I'm also threatening your Pawn on A2
well I'm I'm thinking
I was thinking to go A4 right and then
after this I was thinking to do this
however you do have that idea
which I'm sure you'll play
and um
what is happening now
I don't give up that easily no I I I'm
not saying this is good for um black if
you play F5 to guard your Pawn
keep guarding them yeah okay
well now maybe I should give up now
because I tried everything possible and
well but you could also put the Rook on
C1 instead of D1 to begin with so that
that's another variation here
I I'm saying before you play Rook D1
it's in this position in this position
you could put it on C1 yeah then if we
do Rook C1 now and I guarded the night
but I also have an extracted the night
either so like they're saying there are
multiple
Booms that do not appear
to us in the mission game okay now they
appear now they appeared we have
additional moves they went from the line
I'm telling you I am Sabine is a genius
here today
maybe now now it was the right time you
know I've done some training maybe now I
should have played some tournament but
unfortunately
I wish I would play this good when I
play my own games you know when
it likes me internally I know I trust me
I've played some horrifically I would
have blundered this yeah so they went
for the whoa B5 okay well that's a move
we did not consider at all but I I think
you saw the Trap I I think that's a
great move by white because he's going
to basically Force the trade of the b
and a pawn we were we were too passive
with white a lot yeah we were we were
just yeah
but okay so
yes the problem is although black is
entering the box of this one which is
this one
um because this one pushes with Tempo we
do not manage to catch the pawn with the
King it's one way even if you're in the
Box you don't catch it that or if the
pawn you know is on the starting square
and it goes like this so you have to be
able to be closer in the Box
okay so what to do here with black I
think we still should play here
and the thing is in this position black
has threats like this and this is one of
those kind of ready ideas because now
for example if you try to stop me from
going King E4 I've tricked you because
now I've entered in the box of that pawn
which means when you push I just move my
Rook somewhere wherever and my king is
going to stop your Pawn so that was
just reminding everyone read this idea
1921 but instead we go for basics
and now I haven't quite given the
thought how exactly I'm going to take
that pawn
but I thought I would come this way but
I'm not as fancy as I thought I was yeah
one of our readers is suggesting that
you play
um
Rook B7 you trade and then White's Rook
is on A7
you know to hit the pawn
no I want to enter this way I don't
think you should give up this Pawn I
don't think you should give me that much
compensation but then you don't activate
your Rook so it's that's debatable
let's say if you play King to E4 here I
mean white doesn't have to take that
pawn I mean white
but he probably does because you're
saying you're going to play Rook B3 and
C3 no but I cannot play
I can resign
because my only move is this and then
then you take everything right well I
mean
this has to be calculated of course we
are just going to analyze it
for everyone but but this does not look
still doesn't look easy I thought it was
quite
natural for a way but
um
what is happening here
yeah I mean it's a strong Pawn on the C
file but um
I
I would be surprised if that holds up
for black there to give up both okay you
know what I I mean I I don't I'm not I'm
not going to give you Contour play right
yeah you don't need no let's not let's
not do that let's just do this and and
this point eventually is going to fall
and it will end up having two boss pawns
like all we have to do is just make sure
we get these this Pawn forward the king
coming in and then this should be
winning because you don't have a way to
activate your rug black cannot take the
the defensive approach in this position
he has to be mindful about things so
that I mean I would love to play this
move but I think Rook D7 is just
cutting down all chances
unless the four versus three is winning
right I mean
I don't want to be the no but you you
have no way to get four verses
three yeah I I think when you have four
versus three plus a week
[Music]
if we're getting upon we would oh yeah
if it's King opponents we should be able
to win
yeah yeah we'll we'll just give up there
create a postpone here give it up bring
the king that way grab this one so
that's quite easy
um this cannot be allowed so
I'm going to come up with a better move
for black
um okay so take through K7
again I don't believe black should give
up this one
foreign
yeah I I can't imagine that this is good
for
black but but maybe you've got counter
playing
the thing is that even if you get all
those pawns look for
first even Jokers
but but Rook versus four I mean you know
that it's it's hard it's hard it's hard
oh wow
he got scared
Elia got scared and he allowed this move
King D6 and I think now it's
now a
what is going on here yeah you know and
this just goes to show again how
complicated this is for GM's I I'm
curious what the engine evaluation is
after
um King E5 let's
say 0.3 after but I I'm curious about
line because in in end games is going to
change so this was our line right so
Rook b7c it doesn't give it directly
yeah that's a better way to I just
followed followed the
the the line you suggested but this is a
little bit better for black actually
yeah because it stays on so that's yeah
within literally like that I didn't see
that but this is definitely better for
black the other line was it losing it's
just just as a as a something to as an
idea to keep in mind because Rook end
games are always so interesting
um and
whenever you think you're winning you're
finally finding out that oops nope you
weren't winning okay so this loses we
said that
yeah this this this is this is okay this
only move only move yeah one of the
commenters is saying that we're seeing
the problems that the engine defends and
it's like yes that's a very common
situation that you see the problems and
then the engine finds it so yeah it's
it's not shocking to me here that white
is winning this position if igared just
goes over and grabs the Pawns
I mean practically this is Rook B3 plus
two so most likely is the best move here
but most likely and then you just take
everything and
you could you could hold on to a pawn
for to the panel to be longer if you
wanted to just move but
the engines yeah it's no but but the
other line to that this is so nice
actually is very important this is like
a good finesse to be mindful about so
after B6 we don't go to B7 we go here
let him push the pawn and then get our
rookers anyways we will have to move the
Rook two times but we get it on a square
where it actually keeps our position
protected so now if Rook A4 I thinking
D5 and the difference is now that the
Rook doesn't get to cut us off and get
to D4 and create damage now you just you
know if there's a check you just end up
even losing with white so you have to be
careful not to allow that entrance of
course
so white probably would go here and yeah
okay this would probably lead to a draw
so that's why Elia decided to go King F3
but check that out I just I didn't get
the chance to close the engine but did
you see the change did you see yeah it
goes after King F3 that on King to D6
well because if the king
black is actually winning in this
possession now
so this is an amazing change in the game
and again
rook and pawn endings I I told you guys
a day or two ago I belonged to yaakov
Bogart's killer chess training and he
spent 52 weeks going through rook and
pawn endings he had one class a week and
it's just amazing how difficult these
positions are and even at the Grand
Master Level these positions are just
incredibly difficult and I I know
they're planning on putting out a couple
books this year I think one of them
somewhere in the eight or nine hundred
page range Sam shanklin's going to be
the author of it and they've got us two
of them actually coming out and they're
incredibly difficult
they're interesting if you like this
kind of stuff
uh and you're going to get these types
of endings in your games a very high
percentage it's the most common end game
so you have to know something and it
just goes to show here even at the GM
level how easy it is to to mess up
something not play them well yeah I
don't know if this is going to be really
lost necessarily for white but
um whites has to be in the defensive now
has to find some defensive ideas because
that pawn is going to be lost this Rook
is still very passive and with what
white has on this side of the board is
not going to be sufficient to to hold on
right but if you think about it Sabine
and we're talking about it if the black
gets the king to A4 in this Pawn
structure now the black Rook can Roam
and the white king can't get in there
right stuck right we haven't checked if
B5 was necessarily the best for white I
don't think we checked
it's said that yes that was actually the
best but it had to go with with the
other line where he was actually you
know taking that A3 Pawn like it was
very important to take it now the king
F3 was played he must have forgotten Lia
must have forgotten the ready idea or
something because he you know allowing
this is just is not really the ideal
thing to do and
so it's been a lot of progress in other
games here so yeah we had a result we
had a result in the darish dagupati game
like we already saw that it was heading
towards an end but I think if we go here
this is where we left it off so as soon
as the queens were traded 97 I was the
move players oh he took the exchange
maybe 96 wasn't working I saw a move
after after I suggested I thought maybe
uh he could have given up the he could
have given up the exchange there with
King B7 maybe that's something that
Darius didn't want to deal with so at
least he takes the pawn and he takes
yeah the same the same kind of thing
that happened in the game of course when
you have the choice in grabbing two
Rooks when you forking two and your
opponent gives you the choice you always
want to take the one that doesn't do
anything because the other one is
dragged from actually doing something to
capture your night so you know if he
instead took there this Rook would have
been putting some pressure on the pawn
in D6 so that was you know the right
thing to do and now he just started
taking all the Pawns
a nice game hopefully we'll have an
interview of Darius we haven't been told
anything yet as to whether that is
happening or not but
yes we're looking into it hopefully but
no promises why don't we go to
Christopher U's game where he was
winning according to the engine going
and they've moved a long long way away
from where we were we had this I thought
where Christopher could win a rook by
running oh you know what he
does he ran him out upon those but then
he oh yeah no no no go back go back
right here he didn't play Rook to E2
here is black
why why wouldn't he play Rook to E2
I don't know
because this gets to this zooks Lang
that we were talking about
yeah well right you push F5 and I play
F6 and then what do you do
you can never play Rook F1 or you can
play Rook to D3 that might be the option
that he was looking at that gets him out
of this
yeah that seems to get him out yeah
because if you do this we'll take and if
you have a broken Pawn ending okay so
there was there was a way out
so could he have played Mr B5 should he
have played something like D4 yeah and
it's like but I don't think he makes it
because white can just be like listen
yeah I see your idea I'm not letting you
get what you want
um okay sure we take that and then you
go here so what was more important to
take which Pawn was more important to be
captured
because now we can get the same kind of
position
um you just need to see what pawns you
wanted of them Christopher make very
well
he doesn't need to take that now he can
take here to have that pawn taken as
well
and now
because this can be captured I believe
any time
so obviously I guess
this just leads to a draw right oh no I
can't even
no this is bad yeah I have to go in and
take it we have to go to The Landing
into this line
and
see so maybe Christopher played it
better interesting so
um
you know congratulations to Grandmaster
antipoff for you know finding a way to
extricate at least his Rook out of here
or a piece
but the ending may still be be lost
so I think they've made more moves than
than what we've shown here if we refresh
oh
uh I I just want to say we were in that
position because we're analyzing yeah I
didn't catch up with what happened so
they got into this Rook end game
and he went back Rook to C6 he didn't
want to give the A6 spawn which makes
sense
so now he's grabbing that pawn and so
Grandma's Roundtable is holding on as
much as he can
protecting that pawn so now he wants to
take H5 and Christopher is giving the H
Pawn up
here
okay
well this is an interesting end game
I can't believe him oh he didn't miss
that idea
this is a very typical idea for those of
you who don't know it's very easy to
fall for so there's a check and if
you're not careful and you're going on
the wrong Square you can suddenly
um meet with this move and now your Rook
is blocking
is being blocked from stopping the Apon
and if you trade right now black just
promotes that pawn so this is the reason
why white ended up going with the Kink
back of course you never want to go back
you always want to go forward to support
your past pawns but sometimes you have
to stop
you have to stop this is going to end in
a draw I think I I think so too and a
normally connected past bonds are great
but those widely um separated past pawns
you know Black's got to use his Rook on
one and his King on the other which is I
think going to allow white to come in
and save the game here
D6
this right so you take on H5 with the
Rook right
right how does you plan on saving the
game actually why did he do that
I guess he was losing the pawn anyways
but
okay so is this now winning for black
hair
um no I don't
know TBD TBD well right right but okay
so you play King E4 now
I got my b-pawn guarded and my F Pawn
guard well I can take here yeah I can
take this one I need to find a way to
get one more
yeah that's that's an issue I cannot do
that because there's check check and you
take my
so that's that's an issue now you have
you have this thread actually you have
this very annoying threat and now I'm
I'm in huge trouble I don't even know
okay so maybe Christopher's still
winning the game
[Music]
make an announcement and then she
didn't cheat again too oh it's a draw
people are gonna think we're not serious
let's let's make sure we're very serious
but but we have said no it's a draw and
then five seconds later that's what's
happening in Rook end games for those of
you who you know as as Doug mentioned
earlier and they're not easy people say
you know when you don't know what to do
in a position if you think you're worse
get into it okay get into a rook end
game but you know let's go to VAR
akobian so we're not gonna We're not
gonna just you guys you gotta figure it
out yourselves we will leave you here
we'll leave you hanging
um we'll be back to this game
Doug does not want to take
responsibility for it I'm just kidding
no I'm just kidding I I made my
statement so I have to stick with it so
you know if I'm wrong I'm wrong okay no
yeah I thought it was really interesting
and trying to say because that King F6
is definitely a move but that that is is
a nice kind of um is a very nice idea
because you don't go with the king from
in front of it if you were to go there
then there'll be this check and you had
to go back so white would be able to
push but that move was very very
um
strong
um oh this actually happened no it
didn't King D4 this is this is the
position that they have he played King
D4 not King E4 okay this makes a little
bit more sense actually
yeah the only problem is you're staying
on a on a check if you are on the D file
right but if I play King F6 here well
this helps white to to have that move in
some lines so I think year after we take
and you go King E6 which is the movie
playing right I think so then then
there's going to be this check then we
have that square which with my silly
decision to go to E4 I didn't have
three to hit the F7 Pawn well now I
could do that but I also have possibly
this move I think
and um and the point is that you know
when you take I want to take of course
if you push it
um
I need to double check things but I
believe that in this position if we push
this on
I was going to put it on F6 okay that's
that's fine
I think I think if we keep them cut off
on the back rank
white should be able to win although
they're separated three files
yeah but if you Queen and then play Rook
F7
F5 yeah and I wanna I wanted to play
here and you have this move but then if
this move now you can try to hold on to
this Pawn instead
um
I should be able to make a draw I think
making a scores enough
yeah that's that seems right I think I
could come here and then
it's an interesting I think we should
take a look at a couple of other games
here
um
so they got to this position so this
position
might not be a draw I don't think this
is a draw okay I think this is losing so
you might be right indeed but did they
break it so white played the wrong move
then yeah D7 was well because he didn't
get the king cut off I'm I'm very
surprised that White's Choice was this I
mean unless there's something I'm
missing
um right he could have taken on A3 here
is what we were suggesting yeah yeah
yeah and after King here you you want
this King to go as back as much in the
back as possible
um so we suggested this move and I don't
see if we missed anything let's see if
we're right
that's it for right uh with the
engineering
this oh no it still it says it's still
winning
F6 is winning according to
oh I missed this move I missed this one
oh yeah this is the only move that line
that we suggest yeah this
no it's not it's still seriously
okay
well we've made some mistakes they see
that's why we have to go back sometimes
but anyways
um so Christopher seems to be winning
now so good which game should we go to
next let's go to the can we also take a
break too if you wanted to see we'll
take a very short break and come back
these games are coming down to where
they're starting to finish pretty
rapidly here so why don't we take just a
couple minutes
yes well we're back stay close
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
do
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and we're very excited to take you
through the final moments of this round
five
before the break we were getting very
excited about this game we thought we
knew the result and
we made a few mistakes here and there
but uh this should be a winning
uh end game for Christopher for black in
this position with the two pawns passed
it's not like you can block one it's not
an an edge Pawn that you can trick and
there was one idea that I could have
done but he missed it and this should be
yeah I think the technique here at least
in you because I mean you can correct me
if I'm wrong but I think black can
threaten to bring the king over say King
F7 King G6 and then when black brings
his or white brings his King over to say
F4 to try and keep the black king out
then black can cut the king with Rook to
E5
and um and then I thought your gift
check or gift check right bring the king
back and then push the pawn and bring
the yeah one of these pawns will be lost
eventually and then
um you will get a you will get a Lucena
position
um so now he's gonna play King E6 then
if check King uh came back to F7 King G6
and then push them back and right you
distract the white king you put the
white king to one side of the board and
then you can make progress so this this
is a relatively yeah the good thing for
black is the fact that the Rook is on
lateral so it can help support those
pawns to push forward in some situations
The Rook is behind one of the pawns and
I think those lines are a little bit
more difficult to win
um for
for the the side with the two pawns
looks like we got a result in that game
between
um Ilya nishnik and um
and Fidel Corrales so in this position
after Rook A4
um B7 so black ended up taking that pawn
and white got the king active to D5 so
white probably just
use the King as a restricting
restricting peace
and
there's probably no way for black to
progress this position although he does
want to enter with the King here except
you can't because the yeah A2 is hanging
that was a nice idea
um what Elia came up with to go Rook a
one attracting that pawn to go to A2 so
you'd think that's the right thing to do
but maybe it wasn't yeah I looked at
this a little bit when we were on break
and white was actually okay here because
if black didn't put the Rook on A4 then
you know when white brought his King
over to D4 he was attacking the pawn on
C4 and when with the black Rook on A4
black can't bring his King into A4 like
we had suggested so I I think this
position was probably drawn
um here because black doesn't have a
great Square to put his rook and king at
the same time if I if I can put the
black king on A4 I'm winning
but I can't get there yeah because if
you play here now we have a check which
we didn't have previously and now you
have to block your Rook just maybe given
white even even some winning ideas look
at this
um can we can we go King 6 here let you
promote and then go for the mate I
always like to to show this is nice you
know yes it is very nice and there's
really no easy way out of this for you
know no so you you want to still be
mindful about tactical traps it doesn't
matter what kind of endgame it is there
are still traps and actually I I cheated
in on the break I looked at the computer
and black has to play A2 or otherwise
that happens that you what you just
showed okay okay
let's see that no I know you didn't so
I'm giving you full credit for saying
that and but I love these ideas because
you forget about them so easily you are
so focused
if the position changes you think you're
worse and suddenly you get better and
you just sometimes can make a wrong
evaluation of the position and and it's
very important to stay objective to the
position and not you know just suddenly
feel that okay everything is going great
let's go for
let's go for the win so so this game
ended up a draw yeah so they played a
few more moves
so A2
to ensure that white
um I guess there was no entrance for the
king this idea with with the king
um I don't I had it there uh highlighted
because I was we were talking about the
idea that you wanted to do but
impossible so he checked
okay so he ended up giving that pawn but
this is not going to be sufficient for
black to
um to to win here right because of the
mating threats they just repeat
so I guess why I didn't want to try to
play for more here with a capture of
this spawn probably because
there's no need to yeah if you're losing
both of those King side pawns you're
running some rest here I think is white
because the black king is stopping the C
Pawn I mean it's cut but only by one
file
but how exactly would you
and you're restricted I guess at some
point you'll give me something I'm going
to give you some checks and I'm going to
bring the H Pawn down the board and this
King might end up getting to A7 to
tricked white from going out from that
way so you'd only have to escape you
know this way and then black is going to
give some checks in the back and then
you'll have to go right back so there
would be no progress in that right the
players agreed on a draw here right you
normally have to have the king cut by
two files yes so again it's only cut by
a file here so that makes the difference
so you cannot do the
the the idea that Lucena came up with I
think you just don't have time you
normally could
but don't
well do you
really well white didn't take the chance
yeah you shouldn't have time because
yeah okay
let's go
oh so VAR was able to stay with his
extra Pawn a lot of things changed since
we last saw this position there was a
night trapped lots of things
okay so did you did you get the chance
to look at this I did not look at this
one because I was interested we looked
at Rook to B6 on the break in Rook to B6
is the best
Rook C5 okay so they're similar so they
played
okay okay
all right so
Knight B5 so he was able to take the
pawn and escape with it for a couple of
moves now black took it back 96 we did
see this very unpleasant idea
at some point this Pawn could be
captured oh right now not at some point
he took it right away he took it right
away and then Rook D1 so he stated an
extra pawn and then they got into this
end game very famous four versus three
end game this is the right move for
white to play with black typically in
these in these end games what you want
to have are these three pawns placed in
a diagonal like this
not H7 G6 F5 but F7 G6 H5 the reason for
that is because as white is going to
attempt pushing these pawns forward to
create their pass Pawn every single time
you're gonna be able to trade it off so
they would have to start with G4 you
would trade it then they would go F5
trade trade and on their way to creating
a pass Pawn at least in theory this is
how I like to explain it all the pawns
are traded so you have no you shouldn't
have any issues with black to save
yourself and you usually want it to
happen you want to have the and pause
that way to make it difficult
for white also typically you want to
have the weakness closer to the center
so you can protect it with the king so
that's why vars move is very good G4
because it stops black from going H5 but
black played It Anyways saying you know
what take my Pawn because now if you
take it I will go probably I'm assuming
this move
I'll get the Palm back you've messed up
your pawns and I should be good
but the fireplay G5 another good move I
think so at least he's not going to
trade everything when he has to create
his fast spawn so black still will get
G6
did he ever play G6
he did so black still got this but
he won't be able to trade these Pawns in
theory
you know
there's the famous you know Dover redsky
end game manual where you know they said
it was draw then there was a technique
and I can't remember the exact technique
and these get into some very complicated
Maneuvers where white can win in certain
positions so while four versus three is
a theoretical draw it is very very
complicated there's lots of very deep
ideas and I haven't looked at it now for
a number of months so I can't sit here
and say I remember them but a lot of
times you know when white will advance
eventually black will win a Pawn on the
king side and the question becomes you
know can the king you know after black
has to give up a rook for the past Pawn
get in a position where it can Shepherd
the H Pawn say down to H2 and get a draw
because white has to sacrifice a rook
back
I I don't think you really want to have
that H4 Pawn sitting there is white in
this position as a weakness because if
black can you know put his Rook on say
H1 in some lines or G1 and G4 and you
have to constantly guard that pawn I
would think that's helping
um black to draw this possession
I I but I could be completely wrong but
I didn't think the positions where white
was striving to win a rose in in this
structure
okay when either I think even
um Magnus Carlson has a course where he
talks about this position he was able to
grind someone and and somehow win it but
um this I remember this move being good
into this G4 move being good and making
it more difficult for black it is indeed
setting up this Pawn in H4 is indeed an
issue but you kind of have to
play that move
otherwise if you go F4 I have the
feeling that black and just cut the King
right cut the king and it might make
White's life a little bit more difficult
so you want to keep that F Pawn before
you get in your king so that was White's
only choice in this position to to hold
on to the pawn unless G6 could have been
something but now G6 just Rook G5 Rook
takes G6 so that wouldn't work yeah yeah
let's flip through a few moves to see
yeah to see if they if there is any kind
of way but I know VAR is going to play
till the end this
um and trying to to create some some
break
it should be a draw though I mean
well
in theory I think they have landed on
that this end game is a theoretical draw
but there are lots and lots of little
tricks here but I mean you can see with
the Rook maneuver there that black is
trying to be in position and attack the
H4 Pawn to just give some chicken Rook
H1 yes but he has to be careful not to
allow so now I I think the winning try
for white here is you you put the Rook
on F6 and then you try and break through
the E5 E6 and get the G6 Pawn with your
Rook
um I I think that is the way you try and
win this position
and then you get this one and then and
then you get all the pawns if you can do
that I was thinking maybe maybe now
since the Rook is on third drink and you
don't have checks this is a move you can
consider however however this is where
we get this idea into play and now it's
serious because I go King F3 there is
Rook G4 and right right you don't want
to allow that right you don't want to
allow that no so um avar is kind of
going back and forth here maybe trying
to get more time he is the one with a
little bit less time I see we got a
result actually in the game Christopher
you and we Highland tipov let's see the
final the final position of that game
after King D4 we stopped around here
where
we thought there was still some chances
for for white to draw but no okay so
let's see how he ended up he didn't
bring his King to G6 oh he did
I was
yeah see once he had the king cut he
could give that pawn up over there see
the the white king's cup and it doesn't
matter God the king caught at a lot of
squares so now now he's going to uncut
himself and and just win this as a
Lucena
end game
nice
okay this is yeah this was a very nice
maneuver for everyone let's let's play
that again so Rook to D1 he keeps the
king in C7 so that there's no Rook B6
The Rook comes back to get himself uncut
and now he went back to restricting
white skin three files away from that
pawn which means the white won't have
sufficient time to do something like
this which is quite a typical idea we're
trying to uncut yourself but you're way
too far so in this position whatever
came before King C4 and just
support that pawn to win I think we're
down to one live game at this point
unfortunately we have not been able to
get the broadcast of the Brian
um Escalante game against elshon that
position has been stuck on move six
since the beginning of our broadcast but
we don't have the result I do not know
what happened in that game
maybe we can we can get from our
technical right we had some results on
the lower boards
where the the thief beat Aaron Jacobson
and
harshit Raja beat
Acosta kabutsky and uh how it could be
on one against Evan park right Brandon
Jacobson beat Josiah steerman
so those games are done so I think the
only live game that we still have left
is the bar a Cobian ending here and
they've been maneuvering and like I said
I think the only real winning try here
is to put the Rook on F6 and try E5 E6
here that seems to be the only the only
possible way which I have the feeling he
might do because he brought his Rook
back so unless the position has repeated
three times that's probably going to be
the next
thing right and we're trying to run up
round out an interview as we're talking
here so hopefully in the next couple
minutes we will get an interview
these players are very short on time so
you know
I I don't know that there's another idea
to try here as white in this position
you cannot really enter with the King
okay you just don't want to go to it
before
where is he trying to bring in the king
maybe he's trying to take advantage of
the fact that he took the furthest
file and now if you give a check to go
here and is he planning to go for it
yeah I think you want to play Rook F6
again
you don't want to
um give up that H4 Pawn
so he just brought the king a little bit
closer he's trying to get the stroke out
of the way
it's not going to be easy right because
now he's really far from the pond so I
mean I can still you're not gonna place
your rook in that four are you no I'm
still going to try my idea of E4 or E5
E6 but Rook H4 and I get the pawn right
away so I'm just doing a trade there I'm
not making progress
and I play F4 F5
oh you want to play yeah I'm wondering
right I don't think no no no no before
you play E5 yeah I was changing my mind
and what I wanted to do okay
um
yeah I'm not a big fan of the the king
being on C5 because yeah I don't know
that the
this with anything right right yeah I
think you need to try this idea back
though I think you just uh went there
a little bit and then
I'm confused didn't that King go to C5
no
we got to we got new moves
um looks like King C5 was not never
played it just seemed probably he was
thinking to go there and he came back
they don't have much time specifically
VAR only has one minute so maybe he was
thinking to go to C5 and then he was
like no this doesn't quite help me so
are they going to agree on a draw in
this position is he not going to try I'm
really surprised if he wouldn't try
because I I really don't think there's
any risk if you try this idea I'm
suggesting of Rook F6 and then E6 there
you know with the King tucked on F4
right you're not taking any risk
whatsoever yeah you're not but but also
let's not forget that the
the play another round
two hours so it only takes you 30
seconds to play it and if it works or it
doesn't so I but uh we're told that we
have an interview with um
Rajah Grandma sir Raja harshit who
defeated Costa kavitsky and we are going
to go to Jacob
stay with us
hello everyone I am here with
Grandmaster harshit Raja who's just come
off his win with the black pieces
against Costa kavitsky
tell me sir how did you do it and uh how
explain to the people how you
played a masterful game
um so coming into this game I was
playing with the black pieces so I
wanted to just try to get a game
um and try to get some chances of course
and he usually plays uh D4 for move
number one and he surprised me with one
E4
um so I just played the normal Sicilian
that I do but after Knight C3 I thought
to myself that if I played Nashville
which I always do he definitely prepared
something because that's why he played
E4 yeah yeah so he has to be preparing
if he's playing something new so I
resurplished him with Knight C6 which I
usually never play but I thought that it
would kind of take him out of his
comfort zone and uh I would probably get
um a fresh position from the beginning
he played Bishop C4 and I was already
kind of out of book
um so I just kind of decided to
Freestyle with I guess some of the ideas
that I'd seen in a few games I went
Queen B6 Knight B3 and I'm I think that
I know that they do something like E6
Bishop E7 which looks very normal but I
decided to just stick with my plan of
trying to play completely
um kind of
um illogical in the beginning to get a
freshman yeah yeah
so I plant G6 I do have I mean I do it
does make some sense I mean if I get BG
San and Castle I kind of have a decent
dragonish setup so it decided to
challenge it
and now of course Bishop G7 runs into
takes n95 of course uh so I played this
Queen D2 and here I think I found an
interesting way to challenge his
position I played Bishop E6
um which kind of allows this uh doubled
pawns but the pawn on E6 covers the
crucial Square on D5 and uh I think that
this trades benefits me
so this is kind of an offbeat move I
think which kind of took him off guard
he played Bishop D3 which I thought
during the game was inaccurate because
it gives me time right like yeah you
play Bishop C4 and go back so it just
gives me time
so at six try to kick his Bishop just
developed
now actually I had an option to go into
the end game after Queen E3 uh I guess
something like Bishop E2 and I thought
that black should at least be fine
because you know in Sicilian yeah yeah
black I mean it's just uh it's a very
generic saying that all end games are
black are fine for black and I think it
holds in this case too so Knight G5 I
played Knight G5 just to keep more
tension of course
Bishop F2
win B for castles and I think here I
actually misplayed
um I think Knight C4 should give black
slight small Advantage I took because I
miscalculated something takes takes
takes and initially I thought that you
know I'm just up a pawn here
white does not really have anything but
the more I thought about it after D4 I
don't really have a very good way to
um get out of uh this queen side for my
queen because castles run into Rook A3
and it's kind of yeah
through K4 and kind of a funny Perpetual
at least for white might even have more
and query 6 runs into D5 so the queen is
kind of uh in a little bit of a spot
there so
after reaching this position I'm like
sheesh I can't really take the pawn
and I've had fought a lot at this point
I played castles because I was really
afraid of this strong move Queen D1
the point is that I cannot take because
this traps my I mean it doesn't trap but
I mean you get like a really nice Pawn
structure yeah and also without my uh G7
Bishop the dark words just become very
vulnerable and my queen Still Remains to
be kind of in a tough spot so I was
really afraid of Queen D1
um
that's it uh yeah as I was probably
going to do something like Bishop D4 and
just try to get the game but I think
that exchanging the Bishops was in his
favor anyways he played this and I think
I was very happy to play P5 because I
stopped it looks very weird but yeah but
now at least it doesn't have this
because uh I control the square yeah so
that was my whole point he played King
H1 I just played E6 just you know taking
control of uh the Knight Bishop E3 is
supported very logical Queen c194
Queen C5 P4 Queen H5
yeah and I
now I didn't know what my knight is
doing here even though it looks very
good I felt that it doesn't really do
anything there
um so I thought that let's at least try
to post some roles and here we found an
interesting way Knight D5 I missed this
move
I know I did
because you don't actually think that
you can do this because like you know
after Rook see it it just feels that
everything yeah yeah it feels like
there's a lot of pressure but he doesn't
have Knight F4 which I kind of I guess
didn't see properly uh Queen H4 Queen
into an at least he somehow managed to
resolve the tension
just trying to double and also
protecting over protecting
92 and now he kind of wants to go D4
Knight C3 and stabilize and I wanted to
change the character of the game so I
went D5
because now D4 is not possible and
expert takes and goes D4 he kind of have
to agree that we are playing good Bishop
bad Bishop yeah also double pawns and I
think I would have been very happy to
like just play rookie 8 something like
this yeah and just play this position
just play this position slightly better
but he played Bishop C5 which was the
crucial mistake also at this point we're
also kind of low on time seven minutes
versus 13. so I think this was because
after Rook d8 Knight C3 takes takes Rook
D7
um
this Pawn is hanging if the Knight moves
I also have this cheeky idea of Queen E4
because oh yeah also Bishop actually you
know this bishop can also suddenly come
and give some nasty threats so of course
he took and I thought to just bring the
last piece in the game the night
um get him active yep threatening Knight
C4 can also everything yeah it's like so
it it tried to trade Queens
but the point is after B7
uh he has to go here and I actually
could didn't even see a clear way for
him to save the piece
because uh something like Bishop C5 runs
into Knight C4 and Knight D2 wow and B5
like he did in the game
it's just doesn't work because I have
put a p7 and a funny uh variation to
kind of funny nice relation to the Rook
Beyond which seems that you know yeah it
seems like you might actually be going
somewhere yeah you probably just uh and
now a very powerful move Rook D6
because you cannot take off back rank
mate and visa and have Rook B6
that's actually really funny and if the
pawn was on E5 this works for white
which is crazy yeah yeah because you
don't have Rook D6 yeah and I don't have
any way actually I have Rook D5 actually
any Rook move they all work yeah because
I just called you just yeah okay I
missed that I missed that Rook D4 also
works because I still want to play my
day yeah yeah so if the pawn was on H3 I
guess then yeah then then things are
different
so yeah
um kind of complicated game but I guess
um I just kept on kind of keeping the
position complicated and in with the
time getting low he kind of made the
final error of course yeah we love to
see that a win with the black piece is
always a very nice thing to see
especially against a very strong kostia
kavitsky how are you feeling going into
the next round
um I'm I mean I'm happy to just play
some chess uh during school it's never
easy to play a lot of Chess but yeah
this tournament gave the opportunity to
play against some really strong players
yeah we love to hear that we love to
help out thanks for coming on man for
sure yeah thank you
all right what's a nice interview thank
you so much for bringing uh Grandmaster
Raja harshit uh to uh send to the
viewers uh Jacob thank you for that
um all right so
that was a that was a nice game yeah
yeah we didn't get the chance to look at
it unfortunately we're really focused on
the top games
um there's some very interesting but his
game was interesting too right it was a
very good game we've had some very
exciting games today I think you know we
looked at some some great games and
right now we're not seeing a final
result in Vara kobian's game with Dennis
but we stopped having moves transmitted
to us so I'm assuming that that game's
gonna end in a draw and I
it is a draw officially we understand
and I I looked at you know in the break
I had this idea of Rook F6 and E5 E6 but
the very simple way for black to stop
that idea is to you first of all you
have to bring your king over to prevent
the the H4 Pawn being taken and then
white can Shuffle his Rook between the
H1 square and the E1 Square once so Rook
F6 and then Rook H1 King G3 and then
rookie one and then you can't progress
the E Pawn at all yeah and if you play
King F2 you just play Rook H1 and it's
just a draw and and so I I think Dennis
played the defense very correctly here
and
um and that's the result
I think we
should bring up this
to remind everyone what was going on
today
so I had the Drone board one
um between Grandmaster and Nikolas
deodoro and Yasir quesada that was an
interesting
um
fight we thought it was going to be an
interesting fight but unfortunately the
players decided to take take
around they took a round off and take it
off with a Nicholas played tremendous
yesterday so I I mean with the two round
a day format I don't think anyone should
say anything about that other than he's
played tremendous chess yes he played
the way he thought he needed to play and
you know yes sir Casada for us is an
extremely strong player
um so to beat him is going to take
another Monumental effort and if you're
a little bit tired that's that's it's
not a bad thing but with that drug
Theodore was joined in the lead by Young
Grandmaster Christopher you they're both
on four points and Christopher you took
down Grandmaster Michael and tip-off
with that beautiful game that we thought
the the open he was familiar with the
the opening a little bit he plays a
little bit too fast and we are worried
about him but he made this interesting
Pawn sacrifice yeah and then things just
got
Christopher played a tremendous game
yeah I mean and he showed great judgment
I think you know I made some comments
that turned out to be incorrect about
the physician and Christopher showed us
why he's a grand master and that his
judgment was correct and he played a
great game
yes
um and then we have we have a
Grandmaster Dr Schwartz came back into
the tournament he's he's getting close
to the lead with three and a half we had
a couple of draws someone else who's
joining the lead with three and a half
well the third place shared Brandon
Jacobson who also won his game against
Josiah's German I don't know what is
going on with that game uh we it was way
too fast uh we we never said something
we never saw the transmission yet
probably
um and uh Grandmaster Raja harshit as
you saw is also joining the three and a
half points players after his win
against Costa kabutsky let's check out
the second page
um some other interesting results there
Aaron grabinski won his game against
Savage
gerbinsky Alice Lee drug and Cena
and okay some interesting results oh I
can see brazon Lazar is actually joining
the lead as well because he had three
points I think he's maybe on three and a
half yeah the lead is a four there's two
players on four all four and
um Nick Nicholas theodoro yes four
points but Lazar brazon is joining the
pack with three and a half right behind
them and the two
um Christopher you and
um their daughter or Nicolas I believe
might be
paired right they will be paired in the
next round
they did not
I believe they should get paired right
they didn't play against each other as
far as I remember so I believe that
might be we don't have the pairings yet
that remains to be seen but we won't be
we won't be we won't be doing commentary
for that round out fortunately but we'll
be back tomorrow
um Sabina will be back I will be back
tomorrow I feel sad that you will not be
joining me tomorrow anymore I'm told
that I will be joined by national Master
Julian perlaco
um four commentary of round seven as
we're approaching the end lots of
interesting games I hope are going to
happen so it's going to be exciting
um again it was wonderful doing
commentary with you Doug I hope we will
meet again in the future I hope everyone
enjoyed stay tuned for coverage of round
seven tomorrow at 11 30 a.m right yes I
wanted to say thank you to everyone
Sabina thank you for being very gracious
and host co-hosting with me and I'm had
previously planned on playing in a
tournament similar to this one out in La
so I'm going to be flying out in two
days and one of the players for the
America Swiss is staying at my house for
the next couple of days for the American
cops so I am trying to play host and
then I'm going to be traveling in two
days so unfortunately I won't be back
but I enjoyed this a lot and appreciate
all the comments on the board and Sabina
again thank you very much and also thank
you to all the technical staff here at
the St Louis chess club that makes this
all possible
thank you
tomorrow at 11 30 with around seven bye
[Music]
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chest capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined 300 thousand dollars in prizes
we will cover all the action live from
the World Chess Hall of Fame from March
17th through March 26th tune in for the
best game in chess streaming live for
more information visit uschesschamps.com
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited